in RSA we had an incorrect definition of
brook trout the definition was brook
trout meant and it listed all these
other non-native trout species like
brown trout and rainbow trout um at that
time the department promised that they
would um deal with the issue of wild
trout management plan not being updated
not being added to be come up with a
comprehensive plan and uh and so as an
agreement we decided to Simply strike
the incorrect definition out of our say
and I had a personal promise from the
Department that this would be handled
within a year it's been two years and as
I um in meetings told them that this
would that the effect of this not being
dealt with would in fact be um
legislating I did meet with the
department and they were very reasonable
I understand there's been a bunch of
Staffing changes that may have led to a
delay that they have in fact just
recently done some good updates um but
this will codify and make make sure that
the wild trout management plan as an
idea stays one of the UH
responsibilities of the department
without um micromanaging what those
criteria will be that should be left to
the
biologists so uh in those meetings with
Department the department indicated that
they were fine with the language um for
the most part uh the fiscal note came
back as quite High because they were
worried about the work
um Native they said that even though we
all know that in courts it's the Miriam
Webster's Third Edition that um that the
definitions go to and that definition of
native has nothing to do with DNA but
biologically they were worried about
having to to genetically test and so I
agreed to strike those words from the
language and if you will look at this
packet this is the updated fiscal
analysis based on the amendment that I
provided um at the request of the
department which strikes the word native
the fiscal updated fiscal analysis says
the department anticipates no fiscal
department uh at that time the division
testified to the commission that they
were fine with this as long as the
amendment was in place and the
commission uh tentatively said that they
would be supportive however later the
commission decided to oppose it
primarily on the basis that the wording
um says Department shall instead of
executive director shall and that is a
amendment also I have learned that trout
unlimited has taken objection to the on
line nine that the department May set
forth additional restrictions in
addition to the restrictions I set here
again I'm only codifying part the main
part the heart of wild trout management
M plan I'm not codifying anything else
but the idea that department say may set
forth additional restrictions they're
already doing that they already
administer the wild trout management
plan I'm not enabling them for anything
they don't already currently do and in
fact that was one of the commission's
arguments is that they already have the
power and want to um not be dictated to
as no Department ever wants to be
dictated to but unfortunately it is our
responsibility so because trout
unlimited has said or is claiming I
believe that uh the May set forth
additional restrictions implies an
increased uh empowerment of the
department I have added as the last page
of that Amendment an identical Amendment
to the one that got the zero fiscal
impact but with the inclusion of one
word which is fishing the department May
set forth additional fishing
restrictions which as we all know the
department is already enabled to so I am
uh a little little bit interested to
know if uh if trout unlimited
understands that the department is
already enable to do that uh finally I
did pass out this this is a picture in
our committee office it's right over the
chair's desk in our committee office and
this kind of this was put out this
poster was put out by the fish and game
department as you can see at the bottom
it says the cold waterer fish of New
Hampshire and this is kind of gets to
the point of the problem actually
because in this entire poster the only
two fish that are actually endemic to
New Hampshire and still extent as in not
exted from New Hampshire we didn't make
them extinct in New Hampshire and are in
fresh water are the brook trout and the
lake trout the rainbow and the brown are
stocked the landlock salmon are stocked
um and the Atlantic salmon are
extrap
so the fact that we say that the fish of
New Hampshire is all these fish that are
not of New Hampshire because we've
stocked so many and in impacted our
natural ecosystem and have outcompeted
our natural and Native species is the
problem and so that's why I commend the
department for the creation of wild
trout management I just want to make
sure that they do um their due diligence
in potentially expanding it and um and
not getting rid of it as some of the
people who are impacted by this are
afraid that they will and with that I'm
happy to take
questions thank you representative do we
have any questions representative kofalt
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question um
my question pertains to the prohibition
against uh fishing through the ice from
the ice um or from any object supported
by the ice um and I don't have line
numbers on the the one I'm looking at so
I apologize it's section 2E y um would
this Pro would this
provision um affect ly prohibit ice
fishing in any location where it is
currently Allowed no this is so this
language including what you just read is
directly lifted from the current wild
trout management plan so the department
has currently prohibited ice fishing
with that exact language in the 16
Waters that are in that program so this
does not require that the department add
to that list there is an encouragement
that they go over and that the executive
director will produce a report at the
end of every rules um change period
every 10 years saying why they did or
did not add Waters what they considered
but it does not require that any water
be added to that program or that any
other restrictions and certainly they
are already enabled to do restrictions
anyway so it's not enabling them to do
anything they don't already have the
do any other questions
representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you talked a lot I
think about sections one and two but
section three is is the review of the um
the wild management trout or the the
trout Waters themselves what's the
what's your goal there my goal is so the
the complaint of the people who are
concerned about our native fish species
in New Hampshire the complaint has been
that the wild trout management plan
appears to have fallen by the wayside
with the Department no Waters have been
added information has gotten more scarce
and so the point of the third paragraph
which does nothing except for require a
report and many many reports are
required of the director usually on an
annual basis this is one every 10 years
so to be consistent with the rules
change process um is to say look you at
least have to list out the waters that
you're considering and say why you're
why you've added or not added or removed
give us the the rationale behind it and
that would only happen once every 10
years but there's no requirement for
them to actually do anything other than
report that they actually are
considering it so that it doesn't fall
wayside thank you any further
questions seeing none I apologize I have
to go across the hall but I'll be back
have
fun the chair now recognizes rep Susan
prelli asked for one minute I'm not
I'll hold people to three minutes but
excessive good morning Mr chair and
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is representative
Susan portelli I represent District 19
in Rockingham Hampton Falls and
Kenington I support this bill I am here
speaking on behalf of several of of my
constituents my constituents are Avid
hunters and
fishermen they enjoy trout fishing and
they want to be able to teach their kids
and their grandkids the joy of what it
means to be out on a beautiful day
hunting and fishing he wants to teach
his grandchildren and works with other
fathers in a similar position to make
sure that they teach their kids they
pass down this very important tradition
to their kids the objective is to get
the kids off the phones and off the
devices and into nature and really
understanding how beautiful our state is
and what a joy it is to enjoy nature and
respect nature and not be on the phone
this has proven to be such a wonderful
program for these kids because they
really get to experience something
that's real and not
virtual however if there are no fish to
catch the kids get bored very easily and
of course they want to go home and play
with their games so I support this
Common Sense build to be able to manage
our wonderful resource and make sure
that there
are trout and these native species
available for many years to come I
believe this bill aside from the
administration of it will be able to
provide these beautiful trout in many
different Waters in New Hampshire so
that kids and grandkids can be able to
enjoy the beautiful sport of fishing and
get out in nature and in make sure that
they're taking part
in teaching their friends and their kids
to be able to Jo enjoy this sport
forever and to be able to support what
we believe in here in New Hampshire how
much we value our natural resources so
that's why I support this bill and I
encourage everyone to think about the
future and making sure that we have
these beautiful fish to be able to catch
thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony today the chair
CSF and three to five minutes probably
less thank you thank you Mr chair
honorable members of the committee thank
you for your time this
morning uh for the record my name is
Fred bird I am the assistant manager of
the nor eastern states for the
Congressional Sportsman's Foundation CSF
uh speaking to you guys today that we uh
at CSF are opposing this bill uh we
believe the legislation is unnecessary
as the department already has the
authority to manage for wild trout New
Hampshire has 16 trout Waters currently
designated as wild trout only uh where
we do not stock so in essence uh the
department already has and does
illustrate a wild management wild trout
Management program should existing wild
trout Waters demonstrate that reducing
or eliminating non-native or non-endemic
Trout Stockings increase the abundance
or health of brook trout populations
again the department already has
authority to expand the number of waters
to include stockings when justified by
science U we also have concerns as
previously uh noted about the ice
fishing issue uh it's inferred that the
direction of the bill requires less
non-native endemic trout stalking over
time as well as specifically eliminating
ice fishing where Native brook trout are
found it is not science-based and will
unnecessarily limit Angling opport
unties in the state the language on line
15 Section e is kind of ambiguous and
could be more dialed in uh so someone
reading updated fishing game digest
would know that you can still ice fish
in certain Waters of the state um and
lastly I I will remark that in the
turkey Woods gobbles equal hunting
satisfaction in the fishing Waters fish
caught equal satisfaction and I can
remember back to being a 12-year-old boy
going down to the exitor river fishing
for stocked rainbow trout and my
satisfaction was was there was happy and
it created an angler in me created an
angler in my friends uh that we weren't
on video games and we were out there in
the Wilds of New Hampshire enjoying the
natural and and introduce resources so
there's a a huge value there and would
like to see it continue so thank you all
for your time thank you do we have any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today
the chair recognizes Nick Martin from
Lichfield representing
minutes thank you thank
you I appreciate the time here today and
I appreciate the time to talk about this
bill um first I just wanted to actually
um make sure you bring the mic close yes
thank you uh I certainly don't want to
speak for representative Reed and I
definitely don't want to speak for TR
unlimited but I think she may have
misspoken her original uh introduction
here um my impression was that tread
unlimited is was not concerned about the
section that she had mentioned they may
have other concerns it was actually New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
that was concerned about the language
regarding uh additional restrictions and
so the amendment to add fishing would in
my belief resolve the concerns around a
potential land owner and Timberland
harvesting rules um that the department
May uh doesn't currently have the
authority to set so um so uh I'm a
lifelong angler and like many people
brook trout were the species that really
hooked me and captured my attention so
I'm here today as an example of why the
well trout Management program in New
Hampshire has been successful and I hope
to explain why I think we need to do
more with it um you know many years ago
I stumbled on a web page that explained
and introduced New Hampshire's wild
trout Management program and the next
weekend I drove to one of those Waters
and it rekindled My Love For Those wild
places and fish um there are a lot of
reasons why I find searching for wild
trout to be more satisfying than fishing
for stocked fish um and I've talked with
literally hundreds of fellow Anglers
over the years um going to shows and
exhibitions um and everyone has their
own reasons for me it's Nostalgia
wrapped in uh Adventure stepped inside
of a puzzle about how to catch those
fish that are native to the water
um as I said other people have their own
reasons uh but I can say from my
experience that talking with many people
interest in wild trout is growing here
in the State uh I've heard that our wild
trout Management program in New
Hampshire could be in trouble and it's
true that no Waters have been added to
protect under this program since 2006
and while I've seen progress from New
Hampshire fishing game in regard to
rethinking the stocking of Hatchery fish
over wild trout in some Waters I also
seen what I consider to be an outsize
focus on an investment in stocking uh
with recent financial investments in
Hatchery infrastructure totaling into
hundreds of millions of dollars while
spending on habitat restoration for
Wildfish remains in my opinion an
insignificant fraction of that number um
the intention of this bill in my mind is
to codify into law and make more durable
the protections under the current
program the fact of the matter is that
the protections these Waters have today
is subject to the discretion of the
department and could be changed by whim
uh by current or future leadership I
think these Waters deserve more durable
protection for their future and this
bill also codifies while management as a
real program rather than just a set of
fishing regulations uh depending on how
you look at this new program um it might
be a call to protect a delicate resource
for the future or it could be a way to
Champion and promote an untapped
resource an untapped interest in Wild
Fisheries that dare I say might even
increase new license sales by showing
more Anglers how unique New Hampshire's
Fisheries really are I think it should
be both of these things the bill
provides a lot of latitude to fishing
game it gives the department authority
to choose Waters it wants to include
immedately sets a floor level for the
fishing regulations applied to those
Waters and it's my hope that the
formalization of this program an
accompanying report will help raise
awareness and support for New
Hampshire's wild trout populations the
most important aspects of this bill in
my opinion are the prohibition on
Stocking Waters and the use of
artificial lures and flies which
therefore prohibits live
bait wild brook trout fac many threats
but the introduction of non-native fish
through stocking or the of Li baate that
compete with those trout for food and
habitat are two of the most harmful
threats but they're also the easiest to
solve for I've heard some concern that
calling out and naming these Waters
specifically could actually harm the
fish rather than protecting them by
increasing the angular pressure on those
Waters um I think it's a legitimate
concern though I would point out that
the waters listed today are already
listed on the department's website
that's where I found them originally
when I um when I went searching for them
um but that's also why this bill
contains the other restrictive and
protective fishing regulations Catch and
Release eliminates the concern around
over har harvesting of these Wildfish
and the single barbless hooks reduces
inadvertent uh Catch and Release
mortality um as Anglers we Face a funny
Dilemma on the one hand we know that as
a group we are responsible for the B
vast majority of money raised to help
protect and preserve our Fisheries so we
need to ensure people continue to
appreciate these fish in the way that we
do
and recruit more angr on the other hand
we bemoan the times we arrive at our
favorite fishing spot and find someone
else already there in today's connected
world of blogs YouTube and social media
I don't think we can keep the names of
these wild trout water secret forever so
rather than fight a losing battle to
keep these secrets I feel we need to
proactively protect them we should enact
regulations that would help sustain
these Fisheries for when not if the word
gets out and the fishing regulations in
this bill I think provide the those
protections I'd also argue that if these
concerns are true that publicizing the
names of waters containing wild trout
would significantly increase pressure
that it would prove that there's demand
for more wild trout fishing
opportunities than exist or that people
are aware of today we shouldn't be
afraid of activating more interest in
Wild Fisheries because I believe this
interest will ultimately lead to a more
active and coordinated efforts for more
people to protect these Waters and
that's exactly the reason I'm here today
Wild Management in New Hampshire spurred
my interest in these Wildfish and I'm
here to help enact those protections on
additional Waters with the hope that
it'll activate more interest and
positive action from others be happy to
take any
questions thank you for your testimony
representative Smith you recognized for
a question thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question you
made a statement that no Waters have
been added since 2006 are you aware of
any reason scientific or not as to why
Waters have not been added
uh I am not aware that um that would be
a good question for the Department
representative um there are many Waters
in this state that are could be eligible
for protection um many Waters contain uh
wild populations of Brook tro um many
contain Waters at the level the density
level meaning the population of fish um
program any other questions
representative Darby you're recognized
for a question thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question so I'll tell
you that um fishing for wild Brook Trail
in northeastern Vermont was one of the
memories that I hold very dear
personally um one of the uh earlier um
speakers representative mentioned um the
reason she supported the bill was for um
promoting you know um getting kids
involved in fishing um this bill
requires uh limits um the use to
artificial lures um I'm wondering so
when I was a kid um I used worms um I
think you you mentioned that I if I
understood correctly that the goal of
that was to avoid introducing a species
which I assume what you mean is um
through minnows um and I'm wondering
what your perspective as a fisherman
from an early age is on the kids using
artificial lures for trout yeah
excellent question um I so my first
fishing EXP experience was worms and a
bobber I think that was true many people
um I personally um my my primary concern
again is the use of fish as bait as
you're suggesting because those Fish can
be introduced to Waters where they don't
belong and out compete native uh species
and um personally I don't have a strong
prohibition on uh on using worms as bait
I think it's a perfectly reasonable
thing especially for kids to use um I
feel this case though that these Waters
some of these Waters uh are sensitive
enough and what I mean by that is the
size of the water and the population of
the fish uh to Warrant more strict
protections based on um How likely they
are to receive pressure and the impact
of that pressure so um I would suggest
that these specific regulations uh
aren't a good fit for every water in
this state and uh I would also suggest
that um I'm not here to Advocate against
stocking in all cas cases I feel like
stocked fish are a great introduction
for uh for younger Anglers um and so um
I think these protections though are
Waters any further questions seeing none
thank you for your testimony
today the chair recognizes Steve angers
from Center
Conway uh representing North Country and
Anglers fast for 5 minutes we're running
slightly late so the shorter the better
recognized thank you thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee um the
North Country
angler is the second longest continually
operating Fly Shop in New
England and it started in 1969 and
obviously uh that business business
would not have lasted for 55 years if
New Hampshire didn't have a ro robust uh
trout fishery um but in addition to uh
to uh being the fifth owner and
protector of the North Country angler
franchise um I feel it's my
responsibility to also represent my
constituents you know there's thousands
of Anglers that come see me every year
and of course every Angler has an
opinion about the
fishing and I will tell you that in the
last seven years that I've owned the
North Country
angler customers are actually excited
about coming to New Hampshire to
fish and um I think that comes from the
new team that's at fishing game I have
all the respect in the world for
executive director Mason you know he's
taken on some of the some of the um
stuck in stuck in the past ideas
including um you know naming a chief of
Inland Fisheries whose whole background
is cold waterer fish in brook trout and
I happen to have met um Chief Timmons on
a trout stream in
Massachusetts 25 years ago so I know the
chief very well and I know that that
wild trout and brook trout are Hur
number one priority and I feel really
super great about that as well um but in
addition to being a fly shop owner um
I'm a member of trout unlimited I am the
chair of the New Hampshire State Council
uh trout management
committee and uh I also feel that though
being in those two positions it was
important for me to participate at the
commission
level and and uh the Commissioners will
tell you I think sometimes they get sick
of seeing me but I make 11 out of 12
meetings commission meetings no matter
where they are I even go down to
Seabrook once in May and get my chance
to uh go to Browns and have my fried
clam plate but um you know wherever the
meeting is I'm there because I feel like
I have to represent my Anglers and my
passion for wild brook trout
um just to quickly segue representative
Smith your question about why no Waters
were have been added um previous
administration did not believe in Wild
brook trout and in fact spun the myth
that there were no wild brook trout in
New Hampshire and that every water had
to be stocked but of course through our
work with trout unlimited you know we
and and working with Diane when she was
cold water Fisheries biologist we were
able to bust uh bust that myth so um and
I think probably one of the one of the
things that uh that uh really makes me
proud to be a granite stator um is that
the governor chose me to be the
conservation group through trout
unlimited and the North Country angler
through business to be on his Fish
Hatchery advisory committee and I will
tell you if you if you have not seen
that report I'd be more than happy to
get you a copy but I will tell you that
embedded in that report to the governor
are discussions and protections for our
wild brook trout so protecting wild
brook trout 20 years ago when the
current program was put into place was
necessary because people didn't want to
believe in Wild Brook chout but I will
tell you that um at least a third of the
customers that come through my
door want to know where to find a wild
Brook out and we are blessed with the
White Mountain National Forest and we
are blessed with the great North Woods
that we do have those waters for wild
brook trout and uh we work very D
diligently I also think sometimes uh
Chief Timmons gets sick of seeing my
face once a month as well but uh I will
tell this committee right now that there
is plenty of work being done to protect
and Foster wild Brook show not only to
protect the resource but because it's
what Anglers are coming to New Hampshire
and buying a license and want to fish
for so um I guess just in conclusion uh
the other reason that I'm against this
bill is that there are already uh
methods in
place that if you feel like a stream
needs to be added to Wild trout program
or needs wild trout protection there is
already a system in place of filing a
petition with the executive director to
ask him to consider changing regulations
protective regulations for a trout
stream or a trout pond and I will tell
you in the seven years that I've been
going to commission meetings I have not
seen one petition come in front of the
of the director or the commission to put
those protections on water so um with
that I'd be more than willing to uh
answer any question questions that you
may have thank you much I repres I
recognize representative
goalie thank you Mr chair and thank you
for your testimony
um I too have seen fishing game what
they're doing in the North country and
you know limit limiting some of the
stalking in those trout streams that are
designated and they are doing a fabulous
job in getting that done my question
goes
to the process and how what happens and
I just F do do you believe
that some of the folks are not coming
forward
for adding Waters because and you as
well as me being from doing fishing up
in the North Country all have our secret
spots that that's probably one of the
reasons why new streams are not being
added well I what I will say is again as
the owner of the North Country angler is
part of the Mystique of the wild brook
trout is finding
them they don't want a list they want to
they will I I sell hundreds of White
Mountain National Forest Maps every year
and it's called Thin Blue lining and
Anglers buy that map and they look at a
Thin Blue Line and they find a trail and
they walk up into the forest and they
fish these places part of the lore of
the wild brook trout is finding a spot
for yourself me
personally um my motto is remote Pond
Madness I have a float tube that goes in
the back of my truck on the fourth
Saturday in April and never leaves it
till October 15th and I hike into remote
ponds if it's not at least a mile in
it's not worth my time and I see no one
I have it to myself so personally
speaking I don't want to see a list of
all my wild TR pawns put on the internet
because I won't have it to myself any
longer followup and one more quick
follow up I
know maybe three years ago where we had
a severe
drought there were a number of streams
small
streams no trout to be found because of
how severe that drought was
um did you just comment on that as
to comes to um ecological system me the
the number one problem we have with wild
Brook shout right now is climate
change and um you know you know the
floods that we've had this season
unfortunately those floods occurred
right when the right when the eggs were
hatching in the
Reds and so I will and perhaps the chief
will speak to this but I do not have a
really good feeling that uh that we're
going to have a good recruitment year um
for trout this year but that's that's a
climate change thing you would be very
hard pressed to show me a water where
the trout fishing has gone down because
of angler pressure I mean Anglers just
don't even kill fish anymore
so thank you any further questions
representative Harvey um I don't have a
list of the speakers so I might be
asking the wrong person this question
but I go to the fishing Game Commission
meetings as well so we've yes we've seen
each other there and I remember one uh
meeting and she smil smiling where um a
very detailed plan about um taking care
of our uh fishery or the fish in our um
lakes and so forth was given at a fish
and game meeting um it it went on for
longer than I wanted it to
but it was it was very detailed so U my
question is um and maybe she can answer
it better than you if we attend those
Fish and Game meetings will we continue
to get those kinds of detailed reports
at the Fish and Game Commission meetings
uh well it's again you know you will get
the actual detail from the chief but um
my experience has been that at least
once every six months one of the guest
speakers has something to do with
Fisheries thank
you representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question uh maybe I'm doing
too much writing and not enough
listening
I caught that you said another reason
I'm against this because there are
already methods in place but I didn't
catch in the
beginning in your statements that you
were against it for another reason and
did I miss that oh the other reason was
was publicizing the places where the
Wildfish are got it thank you
yeah any further questions
representative
Ford thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question and good to see you
here at this committee meeting um my
first well my question is if the program
works and people are talking about trout
why not codify what works right we have
all these things that in government that
don't work and we have them in law but
this does work why not codify it so that
we continue to have this growth in our
trout population in the Anglers being
able to fish in waters with more native
species of trout here in New Hampshire
why not codify so that we know we can
have this in 10 years 20 years 50 years
instead of the hope that people will
continue to um want to do it out of the
goodness of their heart and the love of
fish rather we know it works let's copy
it uh I mean this this is my personal
opinion I'm I mean we're in the Live
Free or Die State the less the fewer
laws where they're not needed the better
that that's just my
opinion thank you followup yes I app I
appreciate that okay sure um um I as you
can see I don't have my computer over I
usually do when when we're in in
hearings just to check up on information
and you said um about the publishing and
other other um testimonies also
mentioned about publishing and I'm just
wondering um the the program the trout
program already published the the spot
and I'm wondering as a as a millennial I
could find everything on the internet
why wouldn't I be a able to find these
secret Waters published for um blogs on
um author Pages angr United Pages things
like that of secret Waters to fish these
trout um why are we concerned that our
department of fishing game are
publishing these spots when Anglers are
already doing so even the the ones at
your remote alone spot probably
somewhere out there on the internet of
the best place to go fishing why are we
concerned about publishing when it comes
to our actual Department of fishing game
well that's true and that that's that's
something that we're going to have to
battle going forward is going to be the
ease of
information but um I will tell you that
I have had discussions with the chief on
perhaps as part of her future Wildlife
Management you know trout management
plan that uh some of these places are
going to need more restrictive limits if
we're going to move forward in that in
that
manner but again that that's something
that can be worked out through through
the executive director through the chief
and through the commission it doesn't
need my opinion it does not need to be
worked out through the legislature thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you so
much I now recognize the last speaker of
the of this bill uh Diane Timmons
game thank you chair thank you committee
so I'm going to start with a little
history and I'm going to try to do this
all in five minutes I promise so um I
think it's really important to note that
um sorry let me start with um on behalf
of the commission we oppose this bill uh
we oppose it for several reasons one of
which the rules are already in place and
this would lock those specific rules
into an RSA that admittedly through
research we've determined that some of
these rules we want to change as part of
the wild trout Management program and um
secondly because we would like to keep
that ability to have adaptive management
and make those changes as research
changes as we Garner information from
various locations the other thing to
mention is that RSA locks a multitude of
waters into one standard and there are
the reason part of the reason some of
this has been idle is because we're
determining that not all Waters meet the
criteria that we currently have in place
and so we're in the process of working
through that and then simultaneously um
also identifying that it is an anger not
an angler thing which of course rules
and rsas pertain to it's actually a
habitat thing we have limit Li mited
conditions in our habitat in New
Hampshire and um that locks us into
small fish small bugs and Anglers on
behalf of several responsive management
surveys Anglers are have a preference
for catchable siiz fish and they're not
looking to Target those 3-in wild fish
that we have throughout New Hampshire
they're hoping to get something bigger
and so that is part of our
responsibility and so with that I just
want to give a little bit of history and
the history is so over fishing has been
a problem in this state for well over a
hundred years we've had issues um where
bass perch you name it we brought it in
we brought in Pacific salmon which is
totally ridiculous but we did it and it
was to provide an opportunity to Anglers
because angling in the state of New
Hampshire is a huge recreational um
activity and so for example 3.5 million
days in 2022 were spent by Anglers
fishing so it is a huge aspect it
provides $1.4 billion dollar to our
economy angling is not going away but in
an effort to maintain angling because of
our poor water water quality we have
resorted to stocking and um and also
obviously over fishing because our water
quality is poor our populations are um
do struggle in some cases and so angling
um through stalking is an opportunity
that allows it to continue so um part of
the issue so we brought in those other
species we're doing stalking as part of
the current management strategy we've
been using technology using radio
telemetry looking at populations that we
know of large wild Brook shout in the
dead Diamond you know looking at those
populations looking at their behavior
their actions and then looking at the
challenges that they suffer and so one
of the big things is connectivity we
found that in areas where fish can move
they do those populations tend to be
larger and also the um areas that are
gated tend to have larger so we know
that capture is a part of it um and we
know that habitat's a part of it so most
of our locations do not have big areas
without culs without dams without um
roads and so we're looking at um stream
Crossings we're looking at habitat
renovation habitat um restoration and
we're looking at um documenting where
these wild populations exist um as far
as someone had noted regarding you know
where these places are uh last year I
created a map that it's a map of our
stocking you can basically look at that
map and know where we stock fish in the
state of New Hampshire you'll note that
there's areas that have transitioned I
have removed all of the um smaller
streams because we know that those areas
do have populations of wild brck trout
we also know that they don't get a ton
of pressure and so there was really no
point in putting brck trout where they
or other trout where they weren't going
to be utilized by Anglers we move those
down to the more popular spots let the
wild fish do their thing up in the
Headwater areas and basically um again
these are smaller fish they're smaller
populations they're not huge um but you
can look at that map and you can
identify every place in the state that
most likely has wild brick outout
because they are areas that I don't
stalk and so um the White Mountains
there's tons of locations so part of the
other point I wanted to make is that
part of this program the wild trout
program had objectives by us we were
looking at providing an
opportunity for Anglers that were
seeking wild trout while maintaining
that population so we didn't want to
provide locations that only had small
fish so just because something's not
listed here doesn't mean we're doing a
ton of sampling in the background and so
we have located over 4,000 sites that
we've electrofished in New Hampshire and
um if anybody's interested it is public
information I can give you that map but
um a lot of these locations the average
size is 3.5 in so that's why I say
they're really small and so part of the
goal of this program was to identify
locations that provided a a larger than
average size opportunity or a larger
quantity of fish to be able to fish over
and so although something hasn't been
listed um of course there have been um
transitions in staff that is correct I
was one of them I'm the one that talked
to representative Reed and made that
promise and then I came here to conquer
it so my apologies to that um and the
program was idle and just recently my
new hire just went back to Pennsylvania
but um again because this is important I
know it's important um we've
subcontracted with him to continue
working on the trout management plan so
that we can actually move this forward
and um start indicating where we are
with the wild trout work that we've been
doing in the background so um just
wanted to make sure I note that
obviously the solution here um we don't
want to keep the the commission does not
want to keep these rules TOS in an RSA
because of the fact that we are doing
science all the time and we we need that
flexibility to make sure that we're
managing things appropriately to meet
the goals so with that I'll take any
questions thank you are there any
questions representative Harvey um first
um Mr chairman I need to apologize to
you I think the my last question I
forgot to address you and thank you and
that was not a slight on my part I just
get involved in the conversation and
move on enthusiasm is a great thing so I
do apologize for that so thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so um I was just wondering if
you um what you're if there I hear all
of these things that you're doing to
develop your um plan for trout
management and they all sound wonderful
do you base your plan on um other states
at all or is it just um New Hampshire
yeah no so so new um so first of all New
Hampshire has never had a wild trout Pro
I mean excuse me a trout management plan
which of course would include stocking
as well as wild trout management so we
have never had a plan so it's a new plan
so we are absolutely using other states
looking at those the unfortunate part of
US versus them so just to give you an
idea um both Maine and Vermont have much
better water quality so our trout
management criteria the initial program
or the current program is 15 kg per
hectare other states aren't even looking
at Wild trout programs that are less
than 50 so our Waters of this and I
misspoke I apologize we've actually done
over 9,000 sites of those we have 4,000
that are showing um or a little over
4,000 that are showing brck trout
presence so we definitely have areas
where we're not finding brook trout a
lot of those are warm warmer locations
Beaver ponds you know that um surface
water influence but um so yeah we are
definitely using other states looking at
their criteria and then we've developed
um our own criteria based that's why
we're doing all of this sampling in the
in the woods and in the setbacks and in
areas where we know wild brook trout and
no influen by stocking have occurred so
that we can actually document what's
happening in our own locations but
definitely size for size so um I can
tell you for example in the dead Diamond
Watershed because I did a lot of work up
there in the dead Diamond wated same
length a 17-inch brook trout yep believe
it or not we have them um a 17-in brook
trout was a pound less than its neighbor
right in the malloway the dead Diamond
flows into the malloway they share
locations on hot ears those fish that
live in Maine were a pound heavier for
the same same length fish so very
different water quality which impacts
everything thank you any further
questions representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question sure um excluding you know
section two which is line 8 which is
where the requirements are for um for
fishing
requirements um we heard that past
administrations haven't maybe
appreciated the um the wild cold fishery
as much what would the um what would the
commission recommend in terms of making
sure that future administrations don't
um don't ignore this important fishery
this the wild fishery in the
future I think that um part of our part
of our future focus is just the
transparency so having where we're
stocking locations having that data
where we're identifying wild brook trout
popul ation you know all of this
technology is is new and it's definitely
something that we're embracing in both
the wildlife Division and the Fisheries
division so I think that inevitably
because there's going to be so much
better um data Outreach and that type of
stuff I think it will inevitably fall
into place to what you're saying so I'm
I'm I guess maybe a part of me doesn't
really know how to answer that but um
that that would be what I'd say that we
we are all on board in trying to make
sure that we're doing stuff responsibly
answering to our goals and our um
objectives and then also making sure
that folks know what's happening behind
welcome representative Brown uh thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question clarify for me I think I might
know the answer I'm sorry oh sorry um
when you say poor water quality you're
not you're not talking about either Dees
or EPA water quality standards no can
you clarify what that means along with
the 15 kilograms per hectare that you
happened to mention short time ago sure
so um the water quality that I'm talking
about is welcome to the Granite State so
unlike our neighbors we have no calcium
so calcium is really important for
exoskeletons on in macroinvertebrates
it's part of their development so
literally this simple because we have
smaller bugs we have smaller fish and so
um until they switch over to a pacious
diet which is that they're eating other
fish that's really when they start their
growth and unfortunately in some of
these smaller locations we just don't
have that but if we um you'll note that
a lot of places in um Southern North the
southern east turn side of the United
States they do a lot of lming like in um
Virginia and whatnot they do a lot of
limestone addition because of their acid
and they're doing that to add that
calcium to change the alkalinities and
to buffer their water systems and we we
just don't have that it's very expensive
it's not something that we could ever do
unfortunately because we have brick
outout everywhere
literally thank you're
welcome any other
questions represent
Khan thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question sure um
in your handout you know you mentioned
that on January 16 the commission had
extensive discussion regarding this bill
and I'm pretty sure that they also
discussed that how if this if this uh
management policy need to be changed or
modified or anything
right yeah did uh follow up Mr
chairman uh did they come up with any
modification or anything that needed or
they they didn't feel that it is needed
at this time no they didn't come up with
any policies at this time because it
they know that the Inland Fisheries
division is working on that currently
and So the plan is to present our
findings and um the management plan
draft at that time and then discussion
will be had follow up Mr chairman follow
up so um in previous um testimony we
heard that in for many years there was
not one petition to the commission to
change or modify this
program
um and also you mentioned that uh the
the commission needs some flexibility to
have not to tie their hand in this uh
program so you don't we don't need
another
RSA
yes thank you y any other
questions Ford thank you Mr chair thank
you sure Chief timens I never know if
it's director or chief great not
director not yet um I I'm just wondering
um because from my understanding I I I'm
one of those people I have to explain
what I'm thinking so get my question
correctly sure this bills BAS basically
saying we want to have this program be
codified and here are the here are the
restrictions that must go on Waters if
they're in this program and then the
last piece which I think um is important
is the reporting every 10 years of um of
this program about the program and why
we're choosing the waters and I'm just
wondering what part of one is that your
understanding of this bill that we it's
going to get codified we have some
restrictions and that there's a report
yeah and that there's a list that um you
know that a list of areas that we've
looked at and then determine whether or
not they fit
correct thank you um so okay so I
understand that so what part of what
part of this bill um outside of the
rules change because you didn't mention
that and I was like oh wait we want them
to change the rules because that's why
we get stuck in these things but part of
the restrictions um or part of the
section two is that you have the ability
to change rules based on what you find
in the science over the 9,000 waterways
and things like that so I'm wondering
what um what exactly of those three
sections make it codify it this the
rules and the reporting does the
commission you the department oppose
based on this because it seems pretty
simple again if it's working why not
codify it so that we can continue doing
it so I'm just wondering what part of it
U the department specifically is is
opposing to codifying this the program
that is working correct why why why
oppose it so working is a relative term
um of those Waters that are currently on
the list I can tell you that some of
those will be removed so we're already
working on that because basically um
there's been no change in um some have
declined I shouldn't say no change
there's been no change in angling
pressure um and the water bodies are
declining and so what we're find well
the population is declined in some
locations and what we found is that it's
really um rules of for Anglers and these
areas um right now some of them that are
on here do not get utilized and the
population is going down which is making
us realize that it's a habitat thing I'm
going to have years with drought I'm
going to have years with floods and um
the population is driven by the natural
conditions in the environment and so so
in some of these locations it actually
would make sense to have Harvest because
these fish only can fit in that habitat
that they have their carrying capacity
is met in some locations and so you get
a decline in population and so um we
definitely want to have the flexibility
for that but as far as like the list and
all of that we're doing it now and so
it's it just hasn't been presented
because of various things changes in
staff I didn't have anybody to continue
the program um we just hired the person
uh Colby uh just a year ago and he's
been he has made some great progress
instituted an angler survey because that
was one of the other things we were
missing is what is who's actually going
you know we have some stuff from
conservation officers and and our work
outside and feedback from the public but
we definitely don't have like a
scientific survey so he created that and
then unfortunately just went back to
Pennsylvania so um again working with
him to get this going but that's the
real Crux is that we're already doing it
the plan is already to move forward and
it was one of those things where um I
guess my personal passion um you know um
is that wild trout are very important
and I do think that they are a part of
our New Hampshire history and I think
that they should remain and so um my
personal opinion and my my personal goal
for my myself and my division is that we
will continue to do this and continue to
manage it appropriately and so that is
the whole purpose of the wild trout
management plan so that we can actually
move forward in a direction that works
and in a direction that can be um
repeated through
welcome representative
Brown thank you Mr chair I'm going to
follow up on representative Ford really
clarifying nicely in my mind something I
thought I had
heard I I thought I heard some say that
this would force fishing game to create
a list that wouldn't be changeable as
the scientific information changed but
that's not what I just heard you say so
the the in sorry in statute there won't
be a list it's still going to be in in
fish and game it's not going to the list
of waters is not going to be listed in
statute it's
not and so you will have the ability to
change that policy-wise
within the department based on
scientific data is that accurate correct
the problem with this is that these
rules that are listed in this bill are
some rules that we want to change as
part of the
program so the list going under these
rules these rules are not necessarily
what we want to have as part of the
program and this RSA makes them part of
that
program
okay I think I got that and rules are
slow and complicated to
update in RSA absolutely right right
okay thank you
yep any other questions sorry law and R
and I'll just have one quick question as
well because representative Brown and
myself both serve on Edna and deal with
a lot of the rule making process going
through um and listening to your
testimony and knowing
that all of this is based on
science-based
information
um from what I'm hearing in your
testimony it's much easier to work with
what you're doing and the program you're
doing with the definitions in rule
making because as we're seeing here the
legislative process takes a long time to
change and when you want to change
something for a certain body of water
that may fall under this criteria that
either becomes over at and you need a
different method of taking
fish it would be much more difficult to
do than having that set in rules similar
to the science-based technology we use
for hunting seasons and the take it that
we do there
correct correct and and I think
something to add too is you know as we
go through these things are changing and
you know the flooding and the drought
are very important so you may have an
area that does get wiped out because
it's you know these are natural systems
we're talking about managing for Anglers
and so it absolutely could be wiped out
and then you have it listed as a wild
trout water and it's under these
criteria but there's no fish left so
having that ability to make those
changes as needed under rule versus law
is important thank you any other
questions seeing none is there anyone
else wishing to
testify I'll close close the public
1029 I'll open the public hearing on
House Bill 1029 and the chair calls
representative
Hill
chairman I know you're a little bit
behind so I'll be brief for the record I
am uh representative Greg Hill I uh
cover the wonderful little small town of
Northfield New Hampshire um just about
20 miles north of here I'm here to
1079 what he said
1029 um to me it's a simple little bill
um just popped out of the legislation
from last year and and I just want to
see if the committee will um help
clarify the the existing legislation um
it's to draw a distinction between
commercial Landing licenses and
recreational uh Landing licenses it
seemed to us that uh the pur of the of
the RSA that it affects is to um is to
allow um lobsters and crab that come in
to New Hampshire to be sold um and
that's not the intention of um of any of
the um recreational people um and so
that's all it's to do is to is to draw
that delineation between recreational
and
Commercial um I'm happy to answer any
questions
questions representative Derby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question thank you if I understand uh
this bill um the idea is you don't have
a um a New Hampshire um you're catching
lobsters outside the state and then
you're Landing in the state but you're
not going to sell them is do I
understand that correctly um 90% of that
yes um there is there is no license
required for uh federal waters U Beyond
miles um and yet there are people that
dive there Andor out of state um in
Massachusetts and hold the Massachusetts
license um but they may be renting the
fellow that that brought this to my
attention um had rented a home in New
Hampshire um but was diving in in
Massachusetts and couldn't bring his
boat here um he said the only other
thing I could do legally is just um dive
in Massachusetts leave his boat in
Massachusetts and then drive to his um
his house in New Hampshire so it this is
just just a clarification thing we
looked at the RSA um we asked the
question actually through the researcher
for fishing game and and that was the
answer the that the way it's drawn um
the recreational person seems to need
that um
that Landing license and it didn't seem
like that was um clear and that's what
is followup thank you Mr chair um I I
just want to make sure I understood
because I think you started that
response with primarily are there other
cases besides the recreational out ofate
you know uh Lobster angler that you're
considering aside from um out of state
but also Federal is what I was referring
to thank
you any further question representative
KH thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative taking my question uh I'm
reading from a handout it says why would
we need legislation to benefit
non-residents of New Hampshire when New
Hampshire resident would not be
providing the same benefit in these um
is is that a question what yes um I'm
sorry I can't I couldn't follow what you
were saying could you repeat that New
Hampshire residents goes to those States
like Massachusetts and Maine they don't
have those kind of you know benefit that
they can get in those States so in new
you're saying in New Hampshire um person
a commercial person or a recreational
person recreational person so so New
Hampshire my understanding is a New
Hampshire recreational person would have
to have a license in Massachusetts you
couldn't do it in
Maine so a New Hampshire person would go
to Massachusetts and use their diving um
license that they can procure in
in
Massachusetts um and and then right now
they could just land them in
Massachusetts if if legally and drive
them here or they could come back by
their own boat um to New Hampshire and
not if they were using them purely for
their own use not
commercially um they would be able if
this bill were to pass they would be
able to land them
here do I I I'm hoping I answered the
too follow up follow up so
what what this handout is saying why
would we need a
legislation to benefit
non-residents no this is benefiting
residents okay okay thank
you I knew I misunderstood it I'm
sorry as the vice chair pointed out the
person who wrote that handout is going
to be testifying next anyway so you can
wait and hear it from
him uh Representative no okay uh any
other questions
seeing none thank you so much for your
testimony today a pleasure to be in
fishing game thank you very much enjoy
the rest of your
day the chair recognizes Jim ton from
seab Brook and the representing the
Yankee Fish Company or
on just room to put mine on that's
all turn your mic on please turn your
mic on and make sure you're close enough
to
it thank you Mr chairman and committee
members uh my name is Jim tatone I'm
from CBR New Hampshire I'm the owner
operator of uh fishing vessel Fly Girls
I'm also a uh the Sea Coast
representative to the fishing Game
Commission but I'm here today as a
member of the Yankee Fisherman's Co-op
as well as representing myself as a
fishing vessel owner
operator this this house bill
1029 it the only beneficiaries of this
bill would be Maine and New Hampshire a
Maine and Massachusetts residents who
launch out of any New Hampshire Port who
um recreationally fish in their
respective States and they'd be able to
come back to New Hampshire and land
their catch without any kind of uh
Landing permit whereas a new hampsh
Hampshire resident who may launch out of
a main port or a Massachusetts port and
recreationally fish in New Hampshire
would not be able to return to those
states where they launch out of without
having a landing permit to uh land their
lobsters it doesn't seem logical to me
why we would give a pass to
Massachusetts or main residents in uh
having to obtain a landing permit when a
New Hampshire uh resident would not be
offered the same
benefit um I I think the The Landing
permits are essential in helping
enforcement collect data on what's being
landed where it's being landed and how
much is being landed and I think it's an
important enforcement tool and I don't
believe this this um Bill 20
1029 is is benefiting anyone in the
state of New Hampshire and I would urge
the committee to oppose this this uh
this
legislation thank you uh before I take
questions I'm going to ask one of my own
what about the New Hampshire resident
who goes to fish in international waters
where it is legal for him to fish and
then comes back to New Hampshire uh if
he's recreationally
fishing why he would he would benefit
from not having to pay a landing I don't
believe I don't believe you can
recreationally Lobster in federal waters
you would need a federal Lobster permit
no you don't in in federal lobsters
you're allowed to hand dive for lobsters
in federal waters which would be the
opposite side of the aisle Sholes just
the fact that the committee researched
and found out the last time a lobster
bill came before us it's it's a known
fact federal government allows uh hand
fishing of lobsters um and so I just
wanted to ask that question and I will
open this up to other questions now
representative Smith thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question what is the cost of a landing
license and what it how difficult is it
to obtain the landing The Landing permit
is uh for a non-resident I believe it's
$500 and I don't believe it's difficult
to obtain it all just fill out an
application follow up followup sorry I
was writing it down what are the limits
on lobster and crab for personal
catch the limit would be you're limited
to the number of traps you can fish
recreationally but I don't believe
you're limited to what those traps can
catch one more followup followup again
and this is my last
one you seem concerned that this is
going to benefit non-residents if there
was a committee Amendment drafted that
this change would apply to New Hampshire
residents only would you support that
well New Hampshire residents who
recreationally fish when they obtain
their recreational license that allows
lobsters thank you
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um but
if they have a recreational license
following um following other
representative's question if they have a
recreational license out of state so
it's not a New Hampshire recreational
license then they would still as I
understand it require a landing permit
so if you get a recreational license in
Maine or Massachusetts so I think that
the question the amendment question
I believe you'd have to have a landing
permit to bring those lobsters back into
the
state thank you any further
questions representative Brown thank you
Mr chair so following up on all those
questions if you're recreationally
fishing as a New Hampshire resident in
federal waters you don't need a New
Hampshire Recreation
license no no you wouldn't okay
therefore to land your fish as in your
whatever you bring in you would need a
landing a landing license at this point
even though you got those in federal
waters without a recreational license
correct all right and I think that's
fine thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you so much for your testimony
minutes good morning thank you Mr
chairman committee members um this
particular Bill
1029 I've read it I don't know how many
times um I've asked actually you know
and and Mr tatone and I have have
discussed it I think there's ambiguity
in the
bill um from what I read and it's in the
last
section A person who was not Landing for
the purpose of sale of the lobster or
crab shall be exempt from the
requirements of the
section so I conclude that this includes
New Hampshire
residents um and I haven't got the
clarity from the meaning of that
statement to understand the bill fully
and I think you should be concerned with
that I think there is a classification
of licenses within the state of New
Hampshire it's a four tier system you
have a recreational
license which is no
sale of the lobsters you have a 100 trap
commercial license which includes sale
you have a 600 trap commercial license
license the no sale recreational license
300 if this does not include if this
provision abates them from a of a
license requirement then the department
loses the revenue of that of that
recreational
license um
so that that needs Clarity and I think
without that Clarity you can't proceed
with considering the
bill
um whether it's to your knowledge or
not the Atlantic State's Marine fishery
controls the management of the American
Lobster in the
Northeast um there has recently been a
determination that the resource has
fallen below a particular Tri trigger
for
Recruitment and subsequently there are
more restrictive measures going in
there's gauge increase
measures uh two of them to be exact
there's gear requirements that are going
to be oncoming so there is some
threat to recruitment of into the
fishery and this is the first this that
has taken place in years and it's got
It's got the concern of the
industry um nobody likes more
regulations but apparent but but this is
going to take place it's already
scheduled to take place the first year
of the gauge increase um will begin uh
2025 I think with
that um you have to take that in
consideration
because what
drives the management measures is
data data that indicates poor
recruitment data that indicates over
fishing data that there's a variety of
purposes when this exemption for a
license goes into
place the only thing that the individual
has to say to when eff ficient game
officer
is I'm not going to sell
them that's the end of the
story the data for what that person has
caught is
lost it's not a
requirement and so with that I think
there is a concern with the amount of
data that's lost in the system right now
to gauge and manage the
fishery um we're opposed to this
we think we don't think there is a
benefit except like I've explained loss
of Revenue to the
department um a variety of other things
I've just mentioned and so um that would
be the purpose of us opposing the
Bill thank you thank you are there any
questions Jeff representative goaling
thank you Mr chair one quick question
right down here um
are you would the wording on line four
also concern you because it says taken
by any means doesn't say by taken by
legal means doesn't say taken by any any
means thank you any further questions
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so I
understand the concern about um loss of
data um do Recreation do New Hampshire
recreational um Lobster Anglers have to
report their catch today yes yes they do
thank you it's a it's a requirement for
them to renew the
license and there is a there is a data
requirement of what they've cost caught
in the last year before they can renew
their license thank
you representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair and and to follow up on on that
question so I understand if you have any
your Recreation license you have to
report your catch to fishing game for
data acquisition if you're in federal
waters do you have to do that if you're
in federal waters and you don't have a
New Hampshire recreational license you
correct you would have to I I I I might
be defer to somebody else but but but I
will but I will say I will say because a
we Federal waters
are there would I would be surprised
completely surprised if there's any
recreational
fishing in federal waters it's because
federal waters goes out to 12 miles you
know here when you take the AL or
shoulds in
consideration it's it's it's it's the
contig contiguous Line in New Hampshire
including the AL of shs so going into
fidal Waters I would I would be very
surprised if there is any recreational
license fishing in federal waterers
thank you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you chair puts on his glasses before he
nud
yeah good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Bobby nud I've
been fishing in the state of New
Hampshire waters for better than 50
years most of that time or the majority
of that time I have
represented represented the lobster
fisherman of this state
in uh Lobster
management I'm a member of the Atlantic
states Fisheries commission Lobster
management advisory
panel uh I'm also a member of their uh
Lobster conservation management team I'm
a member of the national fishery service
team this regulation
uh RSA 211 col 49 D as it stands is
extremely
lenient and it's also
affordable our neighbors our neighboring
states allow no Landings of these
species by unlicensed
individuals regardless of where they're
taken whether they are for sale or
not I personally cannot even make
wholesale Transit through the
neighboring states by land without a
permit I am extremely confused by the
language and the intent of this proposed
change for what purpose is the phase by
any means referring
to unless it is illegal means because
all legal means are covered in the
licensing requirements of the national M
is this proposed revision saying that
any licensed any unlicensed person can
land lobsters in New Hampshire saying
they are for personal use and then
taking them out of New Hampshire
jurisdiction and selling
them to get even more
Sinister is this by any means provision
the precursor to another diving
bell
regulations governing the resource
resources of this state should be clear
enforcable and be beneficial to the
sustainability of the
resource this proposed change uh is
totally ambiguous and as none of the
afores
said thank you very much for listening
to me and I will take any questions you
have thank you thank you so much are
there any
questions seeing none thank thank you
testimony the chair will call the last
uh speaker on this bill Renee zel from
fishing game asked for five
[Music]
minutes and I'll remind you not to read
from your testimony that you're handing
out
just hit the high spots for us good
morning Mr and thank you members of the
committee I will not be reading from my
testimony I will just be hitting some of
the highlights and hopefully clarifying
some of the questions you've asked other
speakers as well along the way um as
other speakers have said Lobster are
managed by the stes and Noah Fisheries
through the altic states marine
fisheries
commission we manage as States for
lobsters that have landed within the
state of New Hampshire that is our
requirement we're required to report or
to collect catch and effort information
no matter where those lobsters came from
each state has that mandate through the
fishery management plan for lobster at
the
commission um and I the The Fishing Game
Commission has voted to oppose this bill
I neglected to say that apologies there
so one of the concerns that we have with
this bill is there would be lobster and
crab coming into the state of New
Hampshire which we could not capture for
our mandate to capture by our reporting
requirements everyone's required to
report including the recreational
Harvesters and then any Salem made in
New Hampshire is also being reported as
well additionally that doesn't apply to
this bill but that is also a component
of our reporting
programs um currently as it stands this
is one clarification a person with a
recreational license in another state or
a person diving outside of the
jurisdiction of New Hampshire could
purchase a state of New Hampshire
lobster and crab Landing license they're
available for residents and
non-residents they're not specific to
commercial or recreational as indicated
the fee for a resident would be
$50 the fee for a non-resident is $500
so you'll see in my testimony we were
more of the understanding that the
intent was that that was prohibitive for
someone as I've fielded a number of
phone calls every year for who is moing
or docking their boat in New Hampshire
but maybe lives right over the Border in
Main
Massachusetts those are the field the
calls that we often field and yes
there's a license that's $500 that is a
bit prohibitive we understand that but
for a resident that's a $50 license it
allows them to do that and would allow
us to capture what we need to on our end
as well the for reference the Trap
license for recreational fishing in New
Hampshire is $40 the helpers licenses so
somebody can be on the boat to assist
you those are $20 so often our
recreational Harvesters get the license
and one or more helpers licenses so
they're paying a fee that is very
similar to that $50 recreational or
resident fee for landing Lobster in New
Hampshire another concern that we have
is that there's all of our licenses
allow not only for the take if their
license is to take but they also allow
for possession transport landing and the
commercial ones allow for sale so that
possession is also an important piece of
this somebody is holding a license while
they have lobster on the water that also
allows them to possess that Lobster and
gives them permission to Transit through
land them in New Hampshire no problem so
there is no means for us to have a
license holder on the water with
possession of Lobster in that case when
everybody else holds a license that
allows for all of those
things um the intent of sale has come up
a number of times so we're concerned
about a loophole that that could create
if somebody has a statement that they
have intent of sale and now they're
exempt from any license requirements
whatsoever the there's allowance for
commercial Harvesters to land some of
their lobster for personal use they're
allowed to take them home to feed their
family but that is all captured under
the normal business requirements and
Reporting requirements of those licenses
so what's to say a commercial Harvester
would be out on the water oh this not
for intent of sale and be able to land
those lobsters as well just creates an
enforcement challenge for those on the
water and a little bit of a loophole in
the
regulation um we are flexible we
understand that this $500 license for a
non-resident is a lot of money this uh
legislation as it's written is not
specific to recreational or commercial
so if that is the challenge we would be
open to working with the committee and
working with the sponsor to amend some
language that would allow for a license
for non-resident recr recreational folks
to have a lower license fee than the
$500
specifically and I think other than the
we had a couple things coming up about
our neighbors and chatting with our
neighbors there is no license that
allows a recreational Harvester who's a
resident of our state to land their
catch in a neighboring state that isn't
that isn't something that's allowable by
licenses they have to hold a state
within that license to do so right now
but a New Hampshire resident for example
who owned more than $5,000 of property
could hold a recreational diving or trap
license in Massachusetts and then they
could buy a recreation or buy the
resident Landing license at $50 and come
into the state and land their
catch that is the conclusion of what I
have for you today and if you have any
questions please let me know thank you
very much we'll start with rep kofalt
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so I I wanted to
verify something that I think I heard
and it it it just doesn't sound right
with respect to everything else here it
sounded like you said that the lobster a
resident Lobster license the
$40 recreational resident Lobster
license authorizes someone to take
transport possess and
land um Lobster so if they're taking it
elsewhere but they have that resident
that $40 resident Lobster license does
that give them the the permission to
also land that or not because it seems
like that's what the bill is trying to
do but I think I heard you say that
maybe I I misheard you yeah so that
license is specific to those folks
fishing with their five traps that's a
specific license I might have to defer
to law enforcement a bit on that but the
that typically the activities that are
authorized under that license or for
that license so that would allow that
person to land their catch taken by
their five recreational traps in the
state of New Hampshire and possess those
while they're on the
water follow up follow up okay so the
the confusion I have
is they need that license to to possess
or transport Lobster taken in another
state no that's a separate license so
that's this license the lobster and crab
Landing license if they took their
lobsters we have many folks who have
this license
so if their lobsters are taken outside
the jurisdiction of the state that
license allows them to come into New
Hampshire Waters with those lobsters and
take them into port and sell them if
that is appropriate to their license
that they hold that clarifies it thank
you yeah you're welcome that brings a
question up for me though uh if I can
ask if I had a license to to uh dive
trap whatever in Massachusetts I've got
my boat boat slip here in New
Hampshire and I decide I don't want to
buy a landing license for $50 as a
resident here I'd rather buy a five trp
license for $40 here can I still fish in
Massachusetts and come through the
waters and land my my lobsters here
because I have my resident at $40 and
save $10 I am not a lawyer nor am my law
enforcement so I might have to defer to
them on that specific question typically
the licenses cover the activity of that
license like I said before and that
activity of that license is fishing with
those traps that that is outside of my
scope seems an interesting question
thank you you're welcome any other
questions representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um in the scenario that you
laid out where um there's a New
Hampshire resident that has a
Massachusetts recreational
license um I think I understood that um
if they're coming back into port in New
Hampshire it's still New Hampshire sure
that has to report that even though it's
in Massachusetts license that's so they
would have reporting requirements
probably under the license requirements
of Massachusetts but how the how the
amend the fishery management plan for
lobster is written is the state of
Landing that has the responsibility to
make sure that that catch and effort is
reported as well as those commercial
Landings so the sale component of that
thank you it was commercial
sure any other questions seeing thank
you so much for your testimony today
thank you and is there anybody who has
not spoken that needs to speak and if so
card Mr Vice chair can we just get maybe
some clarification from law enforcement
on a couple those questions that were
unanswered saying there's someone here
in the room that might be able to help
out if he's willing to step up and and
can chair recognizes Colonel Jordan from
fishing game law enforcement morning I
don't have my Coastal Lieutenant so
you're going to have to forgive me uh
due to Staffing shortages I couldn't get
him here today but I'll do my
best so the question I think that I had
posed that we needed a law enforcement
uh answer on was uh if I being a cheap
New Englander like I am don't want to
spend $50 for a landing license in New
Hampshire but would rather spend $40 for
a recreational trapping license that
allows me to catch in New Hampshire
transport and then land in New Hampshire
yes and I also happen to have one from
Massachusetts because I go to the cape
or what have you and I trap my lobsters
in
Massachusetts can I still land them in
New Hampshire under my recreational
license in New Hampshire now you would
have to have a commercial Landing
license to do that if you if you were BR
recreational if you were going to sell
them no no this is for personal use if I
if I trap my lobsters in Massachusetts y
for personal use Y and instead of buying
you're licensed in Massachusetts and I'm
licensed in Massachusetts and I'm
licensed with a recreational five trap
in New Hampshire okay instead of the $50
Landing license for recreation as a
resident in New
Hampshire could I still land my lobsters
in New Hampshire I believe you can if
you're not selling them so I could save
$10 every year you could save $10 yes
that's the question I had is there
another question um yeah representative
Brown so thank you Mr chair sorry and
thank you Colonel for taking the
question so if I'm understanding this
right now what this is asking to do is
not legal right now is not legal that's
correct thank you yes
yes any other questions for the colonel
while he's answering for us seeing none
thank you Colonel thank you and uh with
that I will close the hearing on
without a pause since we're running late
I'm going to open the
hearing on HB
1148 and the chair recognizes
representative Harvey the sponsor of the
minutes
thank you Mr chair and thank you to the
fishing game committee
um I hope to be brief because I'm not
really going to talk about the bill um
so uh this is the exact same bill that I
submitted three years two years ago um
except I changed an or to an and and I
did that at the request of our Sportsman
uh two years ago when I submitted this
exact same bill I worked with fishing
game for six hours over two Zoom calls
calls uh to craft this bill and two
years ago I had fish and game support
for this bill basically there there's
some minor things but the basic uh major
thing is that it changes the nominating
group for Fishing Game Commission from
Sportsman's clubs to participating
organizations that hold a
5013c
um tax ID number and our and support
Hunting Fishing and trapping and that's
the or that was changed back to an and
and scientific conservation methods
but uh no matter what the wording is on
this bill to me that that's not really
the important issue today the issue is
um is one that I believe many of us have
been looking at for a number of years
and we seem to be on this merry go round
um non-consumptive users feel that they
have no representation on the fishing
Game Commission and yet they pay taxes
and according to the North American
wildlife model Wildlife belongs to all
of us and yet fishing games uh role is
definitely to set limits and methods of
take and i would support that so I
believe that there's many of us on this
committee and um in the house that see
that there may be a possible conflict
between those two issues um I've
presented bills representative Reid has
presented bills um last year the chair
submitted a an amendment and we all take
these bills and we look at them and we
change a word or two here or a word or
two there and um and we still find out
that the bill is just not the correct
one and to me this is the very
definition of insanity doing the same
thing over and over and over again and
trying to get different results we're on
a mar round we we need to stop that um
it it is timec consuming it is costly
and um it is now costing fishing game
money in that they've had lawsuits and
probably we'll uh look at more so we we
just need to to look at this and so my
recommendation is that we actually take
this bill and form a legitimate um
interim study
group and if we do that then what we can
do is we can first of all look and see
is there an issue between the the two
groups that I mentioned uh
previously is there a problem and can we
Define that problem you can't fix a
problem until it's defined so can we
actually Define that problem if there is
one and then can it be be fixed and is
that fix a legislative fix it seems to
me that um over the course of the eight
years that I've been on the committee
and even two years before I was on the
committee so over the course of 10 years
we have looked at this issue at least
eight or nine times and we've gotten
nowhere fast it's so it seems to me that
with that number of bills um being
submitted to this fish and game
committee we we don't we just don't know
what we don't know and to me that's not
good conservation so I would um
recommend that we look at um this in a
new way and sit down with the interested
parties and see if we can um do exactly
what I said define the problem see if it
can be fixed and see if the fix is a
legislative one thank you for your
time and I assume you'll take questions
if we have any sure I have one I just
want to clarify as the prime sponsor
you've recommended interim study so this
can be looked at over the summer yes
thank you very much and I would very
much like to be on that study if that's
um permissible for me to ask the the
chair will take that consideration take
it into consideration and designate a a
team for that interim study as we've got
several interim studies we'll probably
be having a few on different ones thank
you um any further questions
representative goalie thank you Mr chair
and I just want to say that while a
study committee may be put together that
any member on this committee who has
interest is more than welcome to attend
and have their input and so is the
public so uh anytime an interim study
just for members of the the committee
that don't know uh and haven't been on
an interim study committee interim study
committees are open to the public they
are noticed and and public may show up
may attend you may ask for their input
you may invite uh public members to be
part of that um so that's all part of
the process any further questions for
representative
Harvey seeing none uh thank you very
much for your testimony and I will now
recognize the next person who's handed
in a pink card with the understanding
that we've had a request from the
sponsor to interim study this um
representative or no not Representatives
this is uh this is
Jean slepian looks like representing
Bill thank you so much for taking your
today could you please turn on the mic
and make sure you're close enough thank
you it's just so the people that are
watching online can actually here um my
name is Jean slepian I live in Stoddard
in chesher County um I do have a slight
hearing impairment so if you do have
questions for me after my testimony
please don't be offended if I have to
ask you to repeat your
questions uh in November of
2022 I filed a taxpayer standing lawsuit
against the New Hampshire fishing game
department in Treasure Superior Court
the number of the lawsuit uh the file
number is included in the testimony that
I uploaded to the general Court's
website um if you'd like to track down
the
documents uh the the basic premise of my
lawsuit is that it violates a wide
variety of constitutional provisions and
state statutes when a commission that is
unelected reports to no one and is
nominated for the explicit purpose
of promoting and protecting the
interests of a tiny minority of the
state
citizens
overseas supervises and approves the use
of public
funds the state made a motion to dismiss
my lawsuit on a technical issue which
was granted however the lawsuit was not
adjudicated on the merits and the court
did not state whether it was dismissed
with or without
prejudice so it can under RSA 50810 it
can be refiled within a year which would
be mid
April my decision on whether to refile
the lawsuit will be based largely on my
impression of the legislator's intent to
correct the egregious Injustice against
the 87% of New Hampshire's population
who prefer to have non-fatal
interactions with
Wildlife um
unfortunately the bill before you now
will not do that because it still
requires that members of the commission
hold hunting trapping or fishing
licenses for the duration of their terms
and it still requires that nominating
organizations um acknowledge in their
permanent
bylaws the protection and promotion of
hunting tripping and hunting trapping
and fishing excuse
me but taxpayer standing
lawsuits under New Hampshire
Constitution part one article 8 can be
filed by any taxpayer who is eligible to
vote in any
County so regardless of my decision as
to whether to refile my lawsuit if the
legislature decides once again not to
extend um representation on the
commission to the 87 % of New
Hampshire's population who prefer
non-fatal interactions with Wildlife I
do anticipate that several of my
colleagues will file their own taxpayer
standing lawsuits in their own
counties so to give you some idea as an
example of the kind of expenditures that
could be
challenged The Fishing Game Commission
is responsible
for developing funding and implementing
the long-term strategic plan which
guides the direction of the
department the wildlife
program is a part of the long-term
strategic plan so a New Hampshire
taxpayer who is eligible to vote could
challenge every expenditure of the
wildlife
program because the funding is overseen
by a commission whose members are
unelected report to no one and are
nominated for the explicit purpose of
protecting and promoting the interests
of a tiny minority of New Hampshire
citizens New Hampshire Constitution part
one article 8 states that expenditures
can be challenged that have already
happened or expenditures that are
approved
so if a person decided to challenge
every expenditure in the wildlife
program
they would use the state expenditure
register at transparent New Hampshire
which makes it very easy to identify
every expenditure down to the penny if a
judge
agreed that that these expenditures were
unconstitutional the next step for the
plaintiff might be to ask the court to
issue an injunction ma'am we're getting
a little off track here I'd like you to
stay focused on the bill itself please
this is part of the bill no this is
talking about litigation this is not
focused on the on the bill please stay
focused on the bill at hand do you have
objections to language in the bill do
you have objections to specific parts of
the bill excuse me representative Harvey
asked me to explain my lawsuit to you
you're you're out of bounds and I'm
going to ask you to leave because I've
asked you twice now to keep it focused
and you've you've now challenged my own
done
chair now calls uh Kyle Baker the last
Hampshire you're all
set all right that's waved and uh so if
there's nobody else that needs to
testify on this I'm going to close the
hearing on HB
and we will move on to the next I think
we're going to make up some time but not
a lot right we got 4 minutes ahead 11 oh
we do we didn't made up some time we're
going to be uh taking a little break for
4 minutes everybody can go and use the
bathroom because we can't start till
that
thank you everybody we're still on time
uh I'm going to open HB
1532 and the chair recognizes Jonathan
Smith uh from fishing game committee for
the as the prime sponsor of the bill for
five minutes he's handed out 20 copies
testimony thank you Mr chairman my name
is Jonathan Smith I represent the great
people of oopy in Carol County District
5 um everyone should have in front of
them I handed it out earlier I basically
took the bill and Below each section of
the bill I put my words in bold and in
parentheses so you'll reference related
so it keeps everyone on track with the
different parts of the bill just give a
quick history uh this legislation that
you see regarding tree stands and game
cameras was before us last year the game
camera bill was sp14 it went to
Committee of conf conference and was
placed into HB
221 uh on the consent calendar and S
sp15 was a standalone bill that became
law and in my opinion there's some
serious administrative and legal
deficiencies within the current law so
if you open up your testimony before you
and you'll see under Section six of the
bill I'm just going to read it because
it keeps everybody on track this section
six clarifies enforcement currently tree
stands can be erected until December
31st however tree stands can be left in
the woods until June 1st tree stands can
then be rected again on April 25th how
are fishing game officers going to know
if a tree stand in the woods prior to
April 25th has been left from the
previous year or placed earlier than
April 25th in violation of the law my
language clarifies it by allowing tree
stands to be erected from August 1st to
June 1st this requires removal of that
tree stand for a two-month period and
gives fishing game officers a clear way
to conduct enforcement you want me to to
keep going Mr chair you want going to
have questions on each section keep
going okay next section section seven
this section s will give flexibility
between the landowner and the person
requesting to erect a tree stand year
round it will allow a landowner to
permit a multi-year agreement at their
choosing because current law allows uh
States
every agreement must expire on December
31st each year this will give
flexibility to the landowner and
relieving the burden of having to come
back for yearly agreements between
Hunter
and the land owners we can go down right
straight down to section
11 uh section 11 restores the rights of
landowners to control and remove what is
placed upon their property current law
mandates that you must notify law
enforcement to get permission to remove
a tree stand by replacing the word shall
with may you restore property rights to
the owner this right is inherent and
should not require permission from the
government to remove a tree stand this
is no different than if you found a
bicycle upon your land to be clear this
does not give the right of the owner to
claim ownership of that property it only
gives him the right to be able to remove
it uh if the rifle owner requests a
return on that property it must be
returned as per current law this change
is supported by part one article two
natural rights of the New Hampshire
state constitution and I ask you to read
that section while I'm testifying you'll
understand the reasoning behind it if we
go down to next section this is getting
into the game camera area this section
four restores the rights of land owners
to control and remove what is placed
upon their property current law mandates
you must notify law enforcement to get
commission to remove a game camera by
replacing sha with may you restore
property rights to the owner this right
is inherent and should not require
permission from the government to remove
a game camera again this is no different
than if you found a bicycle upon your
land to be clear this does not give the
right of the owner to claim that
property but if the rightful owner
requests the return of that property it
must be returned as per current law
again this change is supported by part
one Article 2 natural rights of the New
Hampshire state
constitution we're going to move on to
section
5A this section restores the right of
privacy to landowners by requiring
written landowner permission for
placement of a game camera upon private
property private property only by
fishing game department staff to be
clear this will not impact scientific
data collection via normal animal
tracking collar and other types of
electronic tracking devices this part is
supported by part one article 2B right
to privacy and part one Article 19
search and seizure of the New Hampshire
state
constitution the next section we're
going to go down to is section
5B this section restores the right of
privacy to land owners by requiring
written landowner permission or a
warrant for placement of game cameras
upon private land by law enforcement or
fishing game department staff to be
clear this will not impact scientific
data collection via animal tracking
collars and other types of electronic
tracking devices this change is also
supported by part one article 2B right
to privacy and part one Article 19
search and seizures of the New Hampshire
state
constitution and I I I want to Branch
off of my testimony to a couple other
areas that I I Envision that maybe
counterarguments to these changes which
are constitutional changes and directly
related to property rights this is
nonpartisan everyone here owns uh land
if you saw a game camera out your back
door wouldn't you want the right to
remove it or you're walking down through
Trails through your Woods wouldn't you
want the right to remove it that is
inherent in everyone's property
ownership there is something called uh
the Open Fields Doctrine or the open
Woods doctrine that it's a 1920 Hester
vers the US uh it was Hester versus the
US in the Supreme Court case where the
Supreme Court ruled that fishing game or
game wardens as I think they worded it
have a right to enter posted land freely
and openly to enforce game laws which I
don't dispute that that's fine that's
actually being contested and going to be
back to the Supreme Court soon anyway on
multiple fronts so I think the argument
is going to be well game cameras placing
them in the woods as part of that Open
Fields auction I I can I can attest and
it's a fact there were no game cameras
in 1920 the electronic surveillance
technology that exists today did not
exist in 1920 I'm not opposed to a
fishing game officer walking freely
using his eyes to observe but game
cameras that that crosses the line uh
another example was I just took a drone
Class part of your municipality at I'm a
selectman in my town
and law enforcement was there and I
asked the very question can drones be
flown freely over someone's property
without a warrant and they said not if
it's in official capacity conducting
official business it will be deemed a
warrant would be required why is a game
camera any different why can a game
camera be placed without a warrant or
just with uh other lawful actions as the
bill as the law says um and game cameras
can't I mean I'm sorry when drones can't
and I I think this legislative fix that
I present before you there's multiple
lawsuits for these very instances in
other states where game wardens have
placed game cameras for surveillance
upon private land without the landowner
knowing without a warrant or without
written permission and there's multiple
multiple lawsuits and this will end up
going to the Supreme Court at some point
in the future um and I just want to end
with if you really think about it it's
kind of hypocritical that uh we as a
legislative body gave permission for
fishing game to put game cameras upon
private land without written permission
or without consent but then we ask
private land owners to get written
permission to place gam cameras upon
private land the government works for
the people it seems backwards there that
they have card blanch to place them but
a person cannot so I'll be glad to take
any questions thank you for your
testimony uh let me start off with a
question because I just want to clarify
sure the bill the way it's written with
that you've presented us would allow
fishing game officer to place a camera
on someone's property if they have the
landowner's written permission correct
or if the landowner is maybe the subject
of the person they're investigating they
could get a warrant
correct okay because you wouldn't want
to ask for written permission from the
person you're investigating absolutely
correct so that allows for the warrant
process correct and then the person the
landowner doesn't have to know correct
okay thank you for clarifying that are
there any other questions we'll start
with representative Tudor who's been
very quiet today sure thank you for
taking my question please turn on your
mic thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
that as I walk across my property which
has hunting stands all over it and I
find them that maybe illegal maybe I
haven't given permission for and I take
them down do I need to create a shed to
store them forever or how long do I have
to hold them for before you know since I
wait for someone to come back and get
them that I couldn't answer at something
I guess you'd have to consult with your
local law enforcement at what point can
I
take ownership of this or consider it
lost and found or do I need to surrender
it to the local police department that's
something to consult with your local uh
police
chief thank you further questions
representative
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question so
um with respect to the you know removing
the property owners uh removing game
cameras and tree St I'm sure you've seen
because I see it all the time on
Facebook people that get very angry when
their um game cameras are removed um are
you concerned at all that this may
result in confrontations between game
camera owners and um Property Owners
well I think that goes back to maybe the
Old Law where maybe in the old way you
could place cameras everywhere freely
and openly I'm not looking to change uh
the current law which states you need
permission to place a game camera so if
somebody's placing a game camera
illegally Al without permission on
someone else's land I don't think
they're going to be raising a stink
because they're saying hey look I'm
guilty I put a camera where I'm not
supposed to I don't think you're going
to see those conflicts especially with
the new law that was passed last year
and I'm not looking to upend that it's
you still going to require written
permission to place a game camera upon
someone else's land
yep any further questions representative
Brown uh thank you Mr chair
um I noticed rereading this last night
that the the landowner permission
expires on December
31st but you can put your stand back up
August 1st to June 1st would it make
sense to modify that December 31st to
June to the last day in June uh in May
so that the landowner doesn't have to
reive permission again in the middle of
that period so I I I think I understand
your your intent there but I think you
overwhelm majority of the populace runs
their life on a calendar year January 1
to December 31 um and to keep it simple
come the end of the year if the person
wants to extend that agreement he's
going to have to say well it's coming up
to the end of the year and I want to put
my stand back out in April I need to get
a new agreement for the following
year thank you and another followup um
and is a permite and a permit the same
thing as owner
permission it seems like there's two
different terms there reference me to
where that is in in the bill let's see
page one line
910 so we get owner permission from the
property owner but on nine and 10 it
says uh excuse me on 10 the permit shall
expire and elsewhere it says permit T
which I can't tell you where that is
right now but should it
say the landowner permissions shall
expire or is that a
typical uh terminology used by fishing
game for landowner permission would be a
permit that's I know that's a little
so you said line nine I'm looking at
line nine 10 line 10 it says the permit
shall expire in December 31st of the
current year right and when may I so
yeah let me just interject here I think
uh repres representative it's he's
looking at uh the the is the terminology
equated between permission and and
permit I.E if you get written permission
is that considered to be a permit
correct um and so legally maybe that's a
better question for uh Colonel Jordan
but I think that's in our current law
currently right now so it might be
something we need to fix if it's not uh
if fishing game doesn't consider written
permission to be a permit um I
understand that's that's I think the rub
of and that's the way it's written
currently uh any other further questions
rep Darby thank you Mr chair thanks
again for taking my question on a
related note um about the timing um uh
as was pointed out
you know the ex the um the expiration if
it's a yearly um agreement is going to
be December 31st but is it your
understanding that they wouldn't
actually have to remove it until um if
it expired at the end of the year so
current law again this is I I'm that's
why I'm trying to clar current law says
you can play erect tree stands up until
December
31st but then it says you can leave them
until June 1st so the that came about
last year because there was concern Le
that tree stands buried in 3et of snow
on December 31st someone who's not
picking on old people cuz I'm going to
be old one day or maybe I already am but
somebody who's 75 doesn't have to trudge
in two miles into the woods to get their
stand out they can wait till the thorw
and then get the stand out so that's why
I'm trying to clarify those dates and
again I'm not they still have to be
removed you still have a two-month
window fishing game can enforce you
still need a part you still need
permission you still need I'm not
changing any of
that I'm trying to clarify enforcement
easier thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh I got the Amendments oh you can go
ahead and address the amendment so I
have a quick uh committee amendment by
myself and this was asked on behalf of
of a constituent uh you should have it
in front of you um it goes into section
three of the
bill it says right now it says a person
who places a game camera on the private
property of other or on state owned or
state managed properly shall label the
camera labeling cameras is extremely
difficult there's not a smat a flat
smooth writable surface so the person
asked if I can put a committee amendment
in to say label the camera the camera
strap right or the placard on a tree
with the name and contact information
again you're giving some flexibility so
the camera can actually be labeled or
the site vers someone trying to write in
tiny lettering on the side of a little
game camera so that's what that
amendment's about and rep love is going
to have an amendment also he's going to
speak to on this bill if it's up to you
Mr
chair we'll be taking up amendments
before the exact or during the exact
session so we can get into the details
of all the Amendments at that time okay
uh it just might help some of the
audience who might have wanted to talk
on certain issues to know that there's
already an amendment coming so I wanted
to mention that okay any further
questions from anybody before we say
next no okay thank you for your
testimony and the chair now
recognizes
definitely need glasses for this one
Robert Johnson
II New Hampshire Farm
Bureau opposes the bill asked for one
minute well as previously I won't hold
you to one minute but we'll try to keep
it short because we are wanting to go
get
lunch thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Rob Johnson
representing the New Hampshire Fier as a
federation's policy director and we are
and I'm speaking an opposed to House
Bill 15
1932 the law that passed last year was
very important to our members it was a
priority for us and it was a legislation
that we requested along with a few other
organizations and that law just went
into effect January 1st and our position
time that that uh law that passed was a
a a compromise by a number of groups
working together we there are sections
in in wording that we may not have all
agreed but that we could all live with
and again we ask you to find this Bill
itl thank you for your timing
consideration as always thank you any
testimony chair now recognizes Jason
stock who wrote nice and big so I didn't
need my glasses for that one New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
bill good morning for the record Jason
stock executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
our Members Own and manage Timberland
across the state of New Hampshire we
also represent Forest products industry
loggers Foresters Sawmills our Members
Own and manage about a million Acres
across the state um and as the chairman
had mentioned we do oppose this bill
pretty much for the same reasons that
that Mr Johnson had had had articulated
the current law has been in place it
active for 37 days we haven't had enough
time to see it work our concern is as
you start monkeying with dates you start
monkeying with kind of
requirements um it's going to create an
air of confusion PE fishing game has
already been out trying to educate the
sports
um we are trying to educate our our
members about what is what is required
what isn't and so at this point we're
we're just saying let's be let's walk
before we run here and let's let the uh
let's let the dust settle let's give it
at least a hunting one hunting season to
see how it works and at that point see
if this if some of the issues are really
in fact the problems um with respect I
did I haven't seen the the amendment um
that was discussed earlier here uh we
are very Leary of any placard being
applied to trees we like to take trees
and saw them and so placards sometimes
come with nails Staples Sawmills don't
like those um so again I uh appreciate
your time this morning and appreciate
the opportunity to speak and thank you
chairman and members of the committee
I'm happy to try and answer any
questions thank you for your time
I can you can rest assured that we'll
make sure if there is a placard it's not
attached by any means that's a nail or a
staple um I think that it's covered
already for Bare baiting sites in some
instances where they label a they put an
ID on the tree sometimes so uh we'd try
to model that just to make you guys
aware thank uh if that happened uh any
other questions for Jason stock yeah oh
we do have one yep thank you Mr chair
representative Brown I'm sorry thank you
Mr chair thanks for taking my question
do you have a an idea of when it would
make sense for this to become effective
other than August 1 if you want to wait
sometime again I I'd come back to the
the dates and and we worked with the
chairman and others on setting those
dates um and that was a given take I'd
say again let's let the dust settle cuz
there was turkey seasons that we needed
to accommodate accommodate people trying
to remove stands during winter
weather let's see what H let's let's see
how it works before we kind of reopen
that debate that
discussion you're welcome thank you for
your testimony thank you last speaker of
the day Colonel Jordan from fish and
game who's asked for five minutes which
would give us just enough time before we
go to lunch
okay uh so good morning and uh thank
than you for having me and allowing me
to testify before you today I did bring
a little paperwork I'd like to read from
Mr
chairman he's not paying any attention
but um so I want to start by saying the
commission uh first of all my name is
Kevin Jordan I'm the chief of law
enforcement New Hampshire fishing gain
the commission took the position of
opposing the passage of this proposed
legislation for a number of reasons I
don't like to oppose this is a personal
thing not the commission's position I
don't like to oppose a bill that a
member of the fishing game committee
brings I have a great deal of respect
for representative Smith I think we got
into a very heated debate when this bill
went through I see his side of it I
think he sees mine um so I'm concerned
about opposing it I do
oppose uh pieces of it and I I hope I
can give you valid reasons for that
opposition so just a quick history this
bill came this in
2022 by the Farm Bureau I think
initially brought it and the legislature
listened to it was having none of it and
they defeated it and it was a problem
that we were seeing with our land owners
I was getting that was our my number one
call in the fall about complaints about
tree stands being up no one knowing who
they were cameras up on my property so
we decided that if we I thought if we
didn't get together and address this we
were going to lose access to public
lands and so I reached out we reached
out to the farm bureau in the
Timberlands The Wildlife Federation
which represents all the hunting groups
within the state
we had much debate and and to say that
there were compromise and meetings as an
understatement it went on for a very
long time and the bills themselves uh
certainly were I went to more hearings
on these two bills than I've ever
attended in the 10 years I've been at
the legislature so there was op there
was more than ample opportunity and
there were many amendments put in at
many different stages it went to two
different committees here in the house
it went to the Senate it went to
Committees of conference and so a lot of
this stuff was was debated and hashed
out and at the end of the day I believe
the chairman put in the bill to make it
effective January 1 which I was against
I wanted it immediate and and it made
sense after we discussed it to wait
until January 1 of this year am I
correct in that you're correct and and
we also had to sneak in the turkey stuff
at the last minute in the conference
because everybody had forgotten about
erecting a stand for turkey season right
and so what ended up happening is the
law that is printed in the book it's
printed uh correctly I've reviewed both
laws
extensively um I would remind the
committee to remember this bill has been
in effect for about 30 days a little
over 30 days we haven't had a season yet
um and I worry that we're trying to fix
problems that we don't even know exist
um at this point so I would I I am in
lock step with the Timberlands
Association the Sportsman I think and
and the certainly the Farm Bureau in
letting this go a season and let's see
if we do have issues we have spent we
being the fishing game department law
enforcement division has spent an
exorbitant amount of hours explaining
this both by answering questions uh
putting on presentations you're going to
see on our website here if it isn't
already there it will be this week a
complete presentation a uniform I had a
uniformed officer do where we discussed
labeling the camera what would be
acceptable we wanted to keep that as
simple as we could by just putting a
piece of tape on it with your name uh we
demonstrated tree stands that would need
permits and would not need permits we
discussed what they needed written
permission for and what in fact they
didn't need written permission for uh
and we did that with the mindset that
based on my many years experience with
land owners they're hesitant to sign
anything that allows someone on their
property because they're concerned about
liability I get that I understand that
even though there are laws to and that's
a debate for another day there are
plenty of laws to protect the land owner
the the idea that land owners will say
including the one I hunt on yeah I'll
give you permission all day long but I'm
not signing anything so we we did that
on purpose and I have instructed just so
we're clear I don't know that I want
this on YouTube but I guess I have no
option I've instructed my officers you
will not you will not go out this year
and issue summonses in this just like
any other major law change that we have
experienced the last one being uh lead
for loon and fishing we're going to
spend a year at least in educating
people to make sure that people
understand this because there is a lot
of confusion about it and I think it
comes from the many different amendments
the many public hearings that were held
I we we certainly accomplished confusing
the general public we did that very well
and so I'm working pretty hard to clear
that up if we go in now and got this
after we've done this and put this on
the website we're going to have to
retract all of that and start over again
and I think we're just going to well I
don't think I can promise you from doing
it for 30 years we're going to create
criminals out of people that would not
normally be criminals they're going to
be confused they're confused now it's
only going to confuse them further I do
not have an issue um with an officer not
being allowed to put a camera on without
landowner permission so the reason we
don't do a lot of that uh and I want to
respond to your drone I I will tell you
from uh we have drones we have a drone
team I have a very good drone operator
you're going to read about him here soon
again uh with some of his
accomplishments and we've done extensive
research that's kind of correct but but
to be more on point you cannot fly a
drone or place a camera in a land
owner's curtilage without a warrant or
without that land owner's permission you
can fly a drone or place a camera
currently or go on land in Open Fields
without any um restrictions for that any
law enforcement can not just fishing
game and we've had this debate many
times in this committee so the curtilage
and and so the next question everybody
says well what's curtilage curage a rule
of thumb for curtilage would be any
place that is in control of the home so
what I tell my officers the mod lawn the
the uh uh lawn that's cared for the
Garden area the driveways the buildings
though that is curtilage the Back Field
is not that's not considered curtilage
this has been challenged and one many
many times there's many case laws on
that so he kind kind of told you the
right thing but I think he if you if you
went back to him he would explain to you
that that's the curtilage part he can
fly over their property currently that
may change but right now you can but you
can't fly in the curtilage and and
hopefully that'll never change cuz I
live in America too we use game cameras
because I don't have staff enough
sometimes to investigate all the
reported crimes that we have so the
cameras became a real asset to us when a
land owner said look I got bait on my
property or I've got a I've got litter
on my property or we see that we find
that without the land owner's knowledge
we don't know yet if it's the landowner
or the guy down the road and so we've
put the camera up to Aid Us in that
surveillance the only thing we lose by
this change in your bill would be those
cases just won't be made which is
unfortunate but we we were there 10
years ago we can go back there um
personally I think it's a mistake I
think we've come along ways and we've
made cases with these cameras that we
never would be able to make I don't have
a problem going to a landowner unless
the landowner is the suspect then I do
have a problem and the way I would get
probable cause for the warrant would be
through the surveillance so I've either
if I can't put the camera there that
means I've got to I've got to put an
officer there and that puts some severe
limitations on our ability to make those
so that's I don't have an issue with
that I don't think any of my field staff
does I don't think that requirement is
is um that heavy the rest of it though
is going to confuse people and I and I'm
not convinced that it's necessary I
think we've done a good job with this um
I would encourage as we've said in all
of our public speaking uh announcements
on this remember the landowner can
exempt all of this the dates go out the
window the permission goes out the W if
the land if you go to a landowner and he
says I don't care if you put cameras out
and I don't care if you put tree stands
out then all of this is out the window
there's no requirement at all we gave
the landowner the
authority probably thinking the way
you're thinking Mr Smith that it's their
right to decide decide whether someone
should be on that property or not that's
the way we wrote this and then finally
the most concerning part of your change
and you and I have discussed it at
length the most concerning part of our
change my you the change in this is
giving land owners permission to seize
this
equipment as a land owner I I would
agree with you I think I have every
right to seize that it's my property and
I get that the things you need to
understand is as as a person who's
refereed many of these that never goes
well because people don't recognize that
the landown has the authority to to take
their private property so they're angry
when they go to retrieve it number one
number two and so you end up getting
called very late in the game and you
become a Referee between an angry
landowner and an angry cameraman what
I've seen many times is then the owner
of that personal property will come up
with and and I don't I don't want to say
their stories an owner will come up with
with the idea that my camera has now
been damaged the landowner damaged my
camera and now the owner is civy on the
hook as ridiculous as that sounds he's
on the hook or they're on the hook for
the damage to that property having a law
enforcement officer do that exempts that
or would clear that uh the final thing
and the most important thing to me if
I'm making a case or want to make a case
and a land owner hands me the evidence
that evidence is now rendered useless to
me in a courtroom because I don't have
the chain of custody I can't testify
where that so I bring that camera in and
I say uh U representative sh put a
camera on representative Smith's land
and it was illegal a good defense
attorney would say where'd he put it and
I'd have to put representive Smith on
understand to tell me where that was
where that was done so you get into a
whole custody issue on who control that
evidence who tampered with it you lose
the Integrity of the evidence that's why
when you go to a crime scene there's
tape up and there's people not allowed
in there that's the whole reason for
that if you allow a landowner to seize
that that's gone um most importantly
though you create a situation where
you're authorizing a land owner to steal
private property and it's just a really
slippery slope uh and as far as the
question is when does that become my
property that's a very good question and
no one in the courts in my opinion have
ever really answered that and so they're
very careful about that type of thing
because you're allowing someone to seize
someone else's property I have to go get
a court order for that and I would say
that a private land owner would be
forced to do the same I don't think it's
something that they would want to be
involved in
and then the other thing that I will
tell you is when a land owner seizes
that equipment don't expect the guy to
come running to you to get it back you
are probably never going to see him
again because he realizes it was illegal
it's now gone he's not going to go
looking for it because then he admits
guilt so you're going to end up with a
stand that you don't really know what to
do with so all reasons why we asked that
you go to law enforcement uh to do that
because it's a law enforcement action
that's that's all I have in a nutshell I
hope you forgive me Mr Smith I I I don't
disagree with a lot of what you're
saying I'm just looking at it from a law
enforcement perspective as opposed to a
land owner is very different thank you
so much for your clarifying testimony
are there any questions for the colonel
this makes for some great reading by the
way if you have a boring night have 20
copies of that yeah representative Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you Colonel for
taking my question yes sir um I'm I'm
curious about the portion of it's that
section four on um obtaining uh well the
change is excluding game cameras from
private land unless written permission
is granted and in particular not the the
law enforcement piece um which has been
the focus of the testimony so far yes
but instead the the second section other
persons holding a scientific permit from
the executive director yes can you
describe um whe when those cases might
uh when that permission might be granted
by the executive director um and what
what the used for so it would be our our
biological staff tracking animals uh
tracking uh or or trying to determine
what species are on certain properties
there are a number of times and reasons
various reasons why you wouldn't want to
announce that publicly or want that to
leak out that you would doing a study
about the number of bears in a
neighborhood or you know until you're
sure of the information let's go
straight to rattlesnakes or rattlesnakes
is even a that's even a better point so
we do have rattlesnakes there's a Hu
that's thank you very much there's
there's a black market for that sort of
thing so that is something we do have
rattles stakes in New Hampshire by the
way uh at very Secret locations and we
work very hard to keep those locations
secret we use cameras or the wildlife
division uses cameras to track those
non-game and so in that instance that
would significantly interfere with that
and could cost us that species if it
were to leak out that we have it and I'm
going to tell you from another piece of
experience I know there's other people
in this room that will understand
exactly what I'm talking about all you
and I tell young officers if you you
want to if you want to let out a secret
tell one
person because everybody if you think
about it everybody has someone else that
they're close and will tell and that
keeps going and before you know it it's
out and that happens routinely we use it
in law enforcement as a tool a lot of
times but when you're really trying to
keep something quiet in an investigation
it is your worst
enemy thank you any further questions
thank you for the question seeing none
thank you Colonel Jordan and we have a
late card from representative love uh
representative love I understand you
have an amendment for this if the if you
intend to talk about the bill you can
talk about the bill if you intend to
talk about your Amendment I'd like you
to tell us what the amendment does but
without reading the amendment because we
want to be quick and we don't know if
yet thank you Mr chair thank you
committee members uh nice to be back
here tonight at this this afternoon
rather um this uh this amendment uh
pretty much uh
it it it tells us who who can't post
land uh our current laws say who can uh
but nothing who can't there's no no
penalties um this one uh says that
anybody who does not have uh legal
interest in the in the property cannot
post and there there are fines for it uh
the reason for this is uh my brother
went hunting in in Derry uh went into
went into the woods
and he got a call an hour and a half
later from the dairy police he came out
and there was a a poster you know 15 20
ft from the back of his truck and one in
the front and they were brand new and it
had rained the last four days so we
asked the asked the cop you know what
what happens to a drywall screw when it
rains out when they get wet he says they
rust they rust a lot and he says if you
notice there isn't any rust on those
drywall screws so the cop more or less
said you know they would just put up the
next day he goes back and puts a sign in
the in the window of his truck and said
I have permission to hunt this property
he a land owner's name his his phone
number another Dairy cop shows up and
he's going to run him for Criminal
Trespass okay uh you know that with
without without taking a making a call
or anything uh the problem being my
brother's a 38- year old a 38-year
federal employee uh he's got about three
months to go before he can retire if he
got arrested for a misdemeanor which it
says in there that you know you know
removing signs of misdemeanors and stuff
he gets arrested for for missina uh his
his pension is is is put in Jeopardy
okay let's not get too deep into it
because we still don't know if it's
gerain to this Bill yes um you know that
that being said um you know there are
are posting uh things in in this bill
and uh you know I hope you find it
Germain thank you so much and I'd
suggest your brother give his card to
Colonel Jordan because Colonel Jordan
would defend him about that one as long
as he's got the landowner's permission
there's no criminal trespass he he did
say that in the dairy cop said oh you're
going to call the Colonel you
know I would have said absolutely I am
any questions okay any questions for
representative love about the amendment
that he's going to present to US during
or that we get to look at in ex exec
session none uh yes is the point of
order what what is the uh determination
on germanness here who's going to make
that uh I can ask the clerk to make that
decision we can look at it ourselves and
determine uh if we are in doubt I would
go ahead and submit that question to the
the clerk or to the uh speaker's office
uh typically that's the way it's done uh
the chair and the members of the
committee can can have a discussion
about germanness the Authority for
whether we take it up in the committee
is mine but if I make a dumb mistake uh
I'm going to be held to task so I would
pass it by higher ups at that
point a followup thank thank you Mr Mr
chair um is this a question for the
witness or for me just a followup
question then I'm going to go ahead and
let let you go representative love thank
you so much for your testimony today I
don't want to keep you waiting on this
I'm I'm sorry I'm just are you going to
do that before the exact session it will
be done before the exact session thank
you very much and I this this point I'm
break that's uh
1:30 hopefully we're going to be able to
have our lunch break and be back in time
for that um I will make the comment
because the director intends to give us
also a
presentation
um depending on what we have for a crowd
for that coyote Bill uh and the and the
time that the director has we may need
to recess the bill to allow the the
department to give us our presentation
on the mitigation for the uh fish
hatchery because it's something that's
been of interest of this committee for
six years or more uh and and
representative shirtliff can test to
that um it's it's been a long-standing
thing we've been battling and we've got
some finally some Headway and and they
wanted to present to the committee so uh
we'll see how we can handle that and
take uh care of the the director's time
and his staff as well uh is that okay
with
you is that for us I believe it is it
was I asked for something to be brought
into the room they said they would
accommodate us so that should be for you
to
use and with that let's go have some
lunch and everybody be back here by 1
120 1:30 at the latest and quick uh
quick update uh Dems fourth floor 403 at
115 for a brief
caucus can you let Ellen
know oh you're caucusing before we even
go into the coyote
bill I don't know we're not going to
have a long time so I you know what is
going to do what you guys want I know we
know where we're going I know where it's
so
we'll be starting momentarily uh the
clerk is going to get his timer because
I have enough cards here that I'm going
to be limiting uh testimony for everyone
on both sides of the argument it's going
to be fair it's going to be limited to 3
minutes so we will give you a uh a 3
minute speaking window please work
minutes and as soon as the clerk comes
start
and just so anybody doesn't wonder the
uh the prime sponsor of the bill usually
gets the more than the 3 minutes because
they are the prime sponsor and have to
us all right I believe we are ready uh
if somebody wants to close the door so
we don't disturb people in the hallway
that would be fantastic I'm going to
open the hearing on
hb100 and I'm going to recognize
representative Reed the prime sponsor
from Rockingham
10 thank you Mr chair and thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham ton
New Market and new Fields um before you
is a bill hb100 that would close the
coyote hunting season during their pup
rearing
so the first attempt at this bill
happened in 2019 after the uh
Department's wildlife biologist had
suggested that we do exactly this and um
the commission chose to not um abide by
the the scientists recommendations the
reason that this was recommended then
and has been petitioned for repeatedly
every single year since is because
coyote are the only species that we do
not close their hunting season while
they are raising their young um we do
that with every other Fox every other
canid species including the fox and
every other fur bearing species the
reason aside from the cruelty of
depriving uh the young who cannot f for
themselves depriving them of their food
source and their parents and how cruel
it is to cause them to die in the den of
starvation the specific reason why it's
important to close um the hunting season
on coyote when they are raising their
young is because coyote in particular
engage in something called responsive
reproduction that is by two mechanisms
the first is that typically only one
female in a pack um reproduces or goes
into heat if that female is killed then
all of the females will go into heat
secondly they produce um if a pack
member is killed they will produce
stress hormones that will increase their
litter numbers so if you are killing
coyote while they're supposed to be
raising their young you're actually in
the short term increasing coyote numbers
in in addition to that because now these
pups that have not the ones that haven't
died of starvation are deprived of their
parent while they're supposed to be
learning proper food sourcing so those
pups end up becoming the nuisance coyote
humans now the reason as I understand it
repeatedly that the commission has been
opposed to this seems to be not much
more than stigma the last time this um
bill came board there was there were
comments from Commissioners in hearing
to the effect of have you ever seen a
coyote kill it's so bloody um there were
other there have been other comments
about coyotes lacking moral compass
there's a real stigma like we've had
with across the country with things like
sharks and bats and other animals that
we kind of detest but the science is
behind like we do with all the other
forbearing species closing the hunting
season and to be clear that's hunting
that's going out to kill with a gun not
trapping not Defending Your Wildlife or
property
now I do have an amendment before you um
part of the amendment it's both in
response to um things I understand that
the commission wanted the first part um
kind of opens up more um ability for the
commission to uh establish these rules
so it's not just the executive director
but also that the commission can direct
the
director the last section um instead of
having an actual and I'm looking at the
wrong page instead of having an actual
open and close date um as in the
original bill um it simply says to keep
it consistent with the other caned
species red and gray fox and it gives
the department a month leeway on either
side of that um already exist existing
so just to be clear red and gray fox uh
hunting is closed April 1st to through
August 31st so there's an additional
month on the the beginning of that an
additional month on the end of that
where the department can decide later
through rules to move that back or
forward for example if climate change
causes uh coyote in the future to start
breeding
sooner but so it unti the hands of the
commission or the department to be able
to set that but it does say it has to be
consistent with the fox species the
other caned species and with that I'm
happy to take
questions thank you member for
introducing the bill are there any
questions for representative
Reed representative
Ford thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I just want to make
sure I understand because I have to do
that are there other um laws rsas that
protect other animals that wouldn't
necessarily be um just at the whim of
the fish and game department are there
actual laws protecting the The Fox and
the other kenam Bas animals I'm unclear
exactly which laws um apply to Fox in
particular or any you species in par
other than endangered and threatened
species um but it is the practice of all
committees and the legislative branch in
general to put into RSA things that
departments their respective departments
need to do and we've done that here in
this Committee just this
year thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
time we will start the 3 minutes because
the prime is done speaking so by the
time you start your mic you will have
your three
minutes I will call Deborah
Sergeant chair recognizes Deborah
Sergeant who was opposed to the bill for
five minutes but you'll get three sorry
for
that hi my name is deorah Sargeant from
Epsom New Hampshire uh indiscriminate
killing of coyotes temporarily decreases
the population onethird of a vacancy in
a territory and the coyote is able to
fill it currently the coyotes are
controlled by an Open Season New
Hampshire coyote population is
approximately 4500
coyotes fishing game states that about
70% of the coyotes die in their first
year due to natural causes disease birth
defects or altercation with vehicles the
other 30% are managed through the
licensed Hunter and no not all
6,600 licensed Hunters hunt
coyotes despite all those Hunters it
hasn't reduced the population the
question frequently asks are are coyotes
a threat to humans we know in
neighborhoods at both day and night pets
such as cats dogs other Wildlife are
very much at risk and yes small children
and adults have been injured and a few
killed
one or 100 does not really matter yes
they are a threat as Eric ORF States
he's the New Hampshire wildlife
biologist and he would say conservation
matters I say to keep the kote season
open year round and include night
hunting all year thank
you thank you for your testimony will
you take any questions if anybody has
any sure does anybody have any questions
question representative Brown thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question could you repeat the numbers
that you said uh because I couldn't
write that fast okay so there in terms
of coyotes there's approximately 4500
6,600 licensed uh hunters in New
Hampshire y thank you yep thank you for
your testimony are there any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank you we'll now uh recognize Chris
shadler from Webster New Hampshire from
the New Hampshire wildlife
Coalition who supports the bill and uh
we'll get three
minutes
and I will remind you that uh when when
you are a lobbyist for an organization
or such don't read from your testimony
please we we can read so uh hit the
Highlight but don't read thank
you okay thank you very much thanks for
the time
um we don't have any idea how many
coyotes there are out there nobody's
keeping track nobody has studied them
fishing game doesn't have the resources
to study them UNH has not studied them
so the kind of numbers that you just
heard may or may not be true we just
don't no
um the tradition in the state since the
1940s has been to allow an open season
on coyotes uh because there was a
perceived threat that coyotes would
eliminate the deer herd and I heard this
for years and years and years and years
and that has not come to pass uh coyotes
across the entire Northeast have not
made a dent in the deer herd do coyotes
hunt deer they do they hunt fawn on in
the spring and they can take adult deer
but they've not been able to make a dent
in the
population
um the big point that I wanted to make
about that is that hunting coyotes does
not control coyotes it never has the US
government and state agencies have been
trying to literally eradicate out west
the coyote eradicate the coyote and have
gone to amazing measures to get the job
done and today if you look at the
expansion maps of coyote occupation they
have expanded their range from the
western states to the east up into
Canada down through Central America and
two years ago just arrived in South
America and they did that they did that
because they are so intensively
hunted which makes little to no sense
unless you understand that they use
responsive
reproduction um as their mechanism to
make up for their own losses so I'm
going to say this more
easily uh studies out west in
Yellowstone National Park where coyotes
are not hunted have found that their
populations actually stabilize when
they're not
hunted they have mechanisms to do that
to keep their population in check when
they're hunted indiscriminately like we
do out here
um they they have mechanisms with which
to respond and there's no need to get
into the specifics but I'd love to if
you want to know more about it so
hunting coyotes according to science has
never made any sense if you understand
how this animal Works hunting them
during their Denning
season
is is so unrod for us because first of
all hunting coyotes in the spring and
the summer there's no reason to do that
um for their pets your 3 minutes I just
wanted to let you know I'm what you're
at your 3 minutes no yes you are oh God
I have so much to
say I'm try to wrap it up as best as you
can okay wrapping it up the pelts are
worthless spring and spring summer and
early fall so that there's no reason to
hunt coyotes for their pelts and I'm
sure that there are other people that
are going to say that killing those
adults during Denning season um causes
can cause starvation among the pups but
worse and this is from a former sheep
farmer worse it puts coyotes that have
not learned their proper prey out into
the world potentially going after my
Lambs other people's chickens
Etc so thank you for your time thank you
are there any questions oh sorry rep
Ford you can go just real quick thank
you Mr chairman um you you um we talked
about the numbers are you saying the
numbers that were shared previously from
a witness are high or low I don't know
okay I really and all honestly I don't
know what that figure is thank you rep
Brown thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question um you you said that
I believe the US government has been
trying to eradicate coyotes is that
historical or are you saying that's
still happening that is still happening
through poisoning campaigns bounties all
sorts of stuff out west okay thank you
thank you any further questions seeing
none we'll take one more and then we're
going to recess for a short bit to have
a nice presentation from the fish and
game department on how they're
remediating our uh fish farming
activities to try to clean our Waters up
um
close representing himself I know you've
three and I welcome you back to the
fishing game committee after so many
years of
service for those who don't know rep
close has been a member of this
Committee in the past for a long time
good afternoon Mr chair
committee I'm not in favor of this bill
whatsoever we've had this bill being on
this committee for 10 years we've had
this bill many times in front of us it
changes from time to time but basically
it's the same thing about not uh no
hunting during the season that pups are
born well if you're aware of it when
pups are born they only depend on the
adult for about two weeks and then
they're on their own so for making
months of no hunting it just don't even
make sense when this bill was first made
I was that was about I don't know 15
years
ago we had
hunting 7 days a week 24 hours a day all
year
long and with the director we had at
that time he said it caused too much
turmoil and he wanted to abbreviate it
and this is what happened this is what
we end up with
Bill we gave we refer to 541a for rules
and regulations from the director he's
the one that makes the regulations for
it and we gave him a lot of leeway and
so far it's worked out pretty
well um I've had a lot of person
personal personally experience with k
with Koy dogs coyotes rather and
um I just don't see no reason not to
hunt him for that
time
um also I was selected by fishing game
to go down to
Georgia uh for the big carcass we had in
Georgia for the Sportsman and also for I
went to the one in Little Rock Arkansas
also and coyotes were one of the top
subjects we talked about down here how
they're multiplying all through the
South Pennsylvania new Mississippi uh
Louisiana and it's a major major problem
so that's about all I have to say about
that thank you so much for your
testimony are there any questions for
close I think we're all happy happy to
see you again John thank you and uh
thank you so much for your testimony
with that we're going to recess for
about 15 minutes for the committee for
the defici game department to give us a
presentation and we'll start again uh 15
bill
right
absolutely
sorry sorry pass this these public ones
if people want them to the to the public
yeah
so oh go ahead
okay sorry about that thank you for the
opportunity again to speak with everyone
and give this
presentation um I will go through as
best that I can and save questions for
the end I
guess
so so my name is Diane Timmons I'm the
Inland Fisheries division Chief and
first questions first what got us here
why are we talking about Hatchery
modernization so a little bit of a
refresher for a little bit of a
duplicate I guess from this morning um
just some history stocking has been a uh
Band-Aid for a long time in New
Hampshire well over a hundred years we
had issues with over fishing for wild
brick trout to the point where in some
locations it was extrap we introduced
all sorts of fun species including
Pacific salmon and so um obviously as
science has um updated us we have also
made changes and recognized certain
species just don't fit in New Hampshire
so that being said um our
recreational fishing in New Hampshire is
a huge activity very popular we spent uh
angler spent 3.5 million days fishing in
2022 from our recent survey and which
contributed 1.4 billion to our economy
so fishing in New Hampshire is a huge
activity stocking is a part of that and
we forever be a part of that and because
we have issues with our water chemistry
we have issues with no um calcium we
have lots of granite being the granite
state unlike our neighbors and so we
have small bugs small fish and in order
to provide those catchable size fish
stocking is definitely um an action that
needs to take place so um I will just go
through um you should have the
presentation in front of you as I switch
too so the other part why we're here is
that um in 2019 we got sued by the
conservation law
Foundation at our po Mill Hatchery for
um discharge into the maram meting River
into um the areas above three impaired
water bodies impaired identified by Dees
the Department of Environmental Services
those locations uh we never violated our
permit by EPA we did not have
restrictions on phosphorus at the time
this is a new item for um the country
quite frankly and um it's becoming more
common today but in the at that time
this was our first issue with phosphorus
limits the new working with advisory
committees and the permitting agencies
um the new permit at Powder Mill
discharge is 12 parts per billion and
that's related to phosphorus in the
water we cannot meet that permit at our
current um operation and part of that is
because as you can see from the images
here we have a lot of outdated
infrastructure we have um we have
outdated operations so we have no
mechanism for us to be able to treat the
water without doing a massive water
treatment plant and that water treatment
plant identified through a feasibility
study was $67 million clearly above and
beyond our budget
and so um as a result we'll talk a
little bit further about the next steps
there in the next slide but just wanted
to reiterate that current operations the
way we're running now all of our
facilities are what are called serial
flow through they start at the top the
water goes all the way through there's
no mechanism valves to turn anything off
if things get clogged then it shuts down
the whole water line to the facility so
right now not a lot of opportunity this
is definitely an outdated mechanism um a
lot of states in the United States have
upgraded their facilities modernized
their facilities to be what are called
recirculating systems and we'll get into
that as well but right now our current
infrastructure is outdated to um
maintain our current production with any
sort of
limits so I mentioned the impaired
Waters so you'll note here the Stars on
Powder Mill and Berlin so those are two
of our water bodies two of our
facilities our hatcheries that uh
discharge into what have been deemed
impaired Waters by the Department of
Environmental Services so there are
three locations below pter Mill and
there's one at Berlin uh York Pond some
of you may have heard of that what we've
done at poter Mill what our plan is is
to reduce our production to 30% of where
we're currently at after the feasibility
study which was a year and a half long
done by HDR engineering they determined
that they think if we drop it 2 30%
which will be our large lake rainbow
program um if we drop it to 30% they
think that we can meet that 12 parts per
billion so that is our goal at Powder
Mill um we we don't want to lose Powder
Mill it's one of our best water sources
maram meting lake is a gravity fed
system we don't need any pumps it's it's
um a great large water source that um we
definitely want to look to the Future to
hopefully be able to come up with a
solution at that time the Berlin
Hatchery what we've done there is
basically remove the area that
discharges into York pond so the West
West Branch raceways are we used to hold
fish in those it's the only location on
the facility that discharges into York
Pond and so what we've done there is
remove those fish out and put them down
below we've gotten rid of The Brood
program up in the north country that was
our brook trout brood for the North
Country we think we can supply that at
our new Hampton Hatchery without any
increase in um production we take those
eggs anyway and so now we'll just um
take them there that enable us to stock
out those large brood and put the FIS
from the West Branch in those raceways
and take their place so that right now
we're not discharging into York pond at
all and that is in anticipation of the
the renewal permit right now Berlin is
operating under a 2013 Nifty permit
National pollution and discharge um uh
permit and we've
basically waiting to have um EPA give us
a level at this point we're anticipating
there's going to be something so you'll
note on the chart that there's a 10,000
um pound
uh reduction here and that is purely an
anticipation of some sort of limit we
have no idea hopefully by taking the
action that the proactive action that
we've taken we're hoping maybe they'll
say Oh No Limit you guys stay the same
and that would be great and then we
could remain back at that 74,000 but one
question for you looking at the chart
yeah if I may um I'm seeing that uh the
the reductions uh because we need to
make them in Berlin and uh Powder Mill
uh seem to be made up by New Hampton um
with it more than doubling uh the
proposed pounds in New Hampton are there
concerns there or do they have some
natural remediation such as um uh
settling ponds and uh natural flood
planes Etc outside of that at New
Hampton are you talking yes New Hampton
to absorb the extra burden we're putting
down there yep so New Hampton nice segue
thank you so at New Hampton where
revamping the entire facility so the
whole idea is this would be our Target
facility to modernize um it's a
centralized location it currently holds
all of our brood for brown trout and
brook trout and um it is an area we have
enough land there that um we can
definitely do it at that location and
then also in future phases um we have
the opportunity to potentially um disch
charge into the pemet river after
research and um anti-degradation efforts
so the thought at New Hampton is that
yes we would be doubling it but by doing
the recirculating systems which I'll get
a little bit in the next slide but um in
doing that uh there's a huge well it's
the only opportunity for us to do
additional filtrations we have uh water
treatment there's a whole bunch of
things there that enable us to operate
on under much better conditions so
because we have the opportunity to add
oxygen to treat to filter Etc we'll be
able to take on that extra fish load and
not increase any of our we will maintain
our limits where we're currently at at
New Hampton there'll be no an increase
so this is uh entirely handled by
mechanical mitigation not any natural um
mitigation through um swampy areas and
whatnot that we've decided we're going
to put in to absorb the nutrients before
they get out to the river yeah so
there's settling areas within that so
there's um Swale ponds that they do
that's all part of the production yeah I
mean sorry part of the um construction
yep and then the other three facilities
ideally in the future we'd love to have
our own brood Stock Program for rainbows
right now those fish come from out of
state I won't lie we get yucky eggs
fortunately we get the seconds and so
obviously the states that are prod
producing them get the primary high
quality ones and we get the seconds and
we have had multiple issues with FedEx
we've had multiple issues with just poor
quality eggs and we spend a lot of time
and a lot of um just effort and just
variability on when we get those eggs is
a real problem for Hatchery because your
your hatch dates are different and so
obviously trying to get to a Target size
by the stocking date can sometimes be a
problem because sometimes instead of
getting eggs in September we're not
getting eggs until you know sometimes
February and so we've had major issues
with that as well we'd love to have our
own program obviously that's a future
effort and um future funding um need but
uh we would like to do that at Twin Twin
has great alkalinities it has great pH
and rainbows respond very well to that
type of water chemistry so we'd like to
do that at Twin and then as far as far
as Milford and Warren um we would
continue to just look at those
future no twin is Carol up north yeah
yep um so getting into the recirculating
part uh so the conceptual Design This is
conceptual we're still working with HDR
literally weekly at this point talking
about things that our hatch Reef what
we'd like to have on station we've
actually traveled down to multiple
multiple facilities that do have the
recirculating type um aquaculture
systems and so in concept we would have
a brand new Hatchery building one of the
other things that um I should mention
too is predation and so people don't
really realize that predation at a
hatchery is just as bad as it is in the
wild and sometimes worse because we
create little dinner plate atmospheres
out there and so we have major major
issues with minks otter Osprey Eagles
You Name It rats we get every single
creature that likes to eat anything in
everything at our facilities and right
now a lot of our facilities don't have
um predation control and so recently in
New Hampton just last year actually with
that ice in the late spring uh well late
winter I guess um we had major issues
with ice and it fluctuated our green
house structures and blew the whole
facility over just like that $41,000
went out the window and we had no
protection on those brown trout as a
result we will be short brown trout this
year um in our stocking because they got
eaten and so predation is huge the other
part is the feeding regime you think
that there's a certain number of fish in
a Raceway you're feeding them and then
that certain number gets lower but
you're still feeding the same until we
do our weekly assessments sometimes by
month
and so you keep feeding them and all
that food settles to the bottom and also
results in a phosphorus issue so it's
it's a combination thing fixing
predation is not just a feel-good
syndrome it's also you know looking at
that water quality and chemistry that we
need to
protect so um so our Hatchery building
would be a brand new facility it would
be 100% enclosed this would be where our
eggs and um Hatchery uh brood fish would
be and then we would have the
intermediate rearing which would be the
level where um we have growout so that
small fish you know 3 in grow to the
next level and then our massive growout
would be a um netting or fabric type
structure that would go over so you
wouldn't necessarily need enclosed steel
structures for everything as much as I'd
love that but you may not necessarily
need it um but you definitely need that
cover and that protection from
Predators just give you a 4-minute
warning yep so Raz just real quick this
is a very simple thing you can look at
it it just goes through like I said it
gives you opportunity for ultra
filtration it gives you UV oxygen
control uh pH you can change all sorts
of things temperature all helping you um
rid bacteria and um Disease Control as
well as U maximizing your growth so
bunch of that image with the big large
blue cover and gray that's just to give
you an idea that's a drum filter they're
tremendous and you would have multiple
levels of areas where drum filters would
be and the Raz system would be in the
intermediate building as well as the
growout it would not be in the Hatchery
building at this
point um now the bad part where
everybody looks at the cost and
everybody freaks out and so um just very
quickly looking at this the um cost
portion so so HDR has estimated of 47
million uh 700,000 cost to this in that
is the construction manager piece and um
construction manager were doing it a
little bit different this time instead
of doing just this design by the
engineers and then putting the whole
thing out to bid and going through the
construction Etc we're doing a
construction manager at risk based on um
Department of Public Works
recommendation in order to meet the
timeline the construction manager at RIS
will work sign simultaneously with the
engineers so that the designing process
happens the material can be chosen the
material can be pre-bought so this
enables us to meet those deadlines to
encumber the money by December
2024 and also look at um so everything's
ready we won't have supply chain issues
because we can pre-order the large items
that we need and be ready for
construction when the time comes um and
then just you one second just pardon me
do you remember how much we passed uh
some six or so years ago for this study
and for for finding out what we have to
do to remediate do you know what the
funding was director why don't you go
ahead and get near the microphone so we
can people on the on the online can hear
what you're saying that's fine you stay
sit Diane I'll just I'll look over you
lean on my should yeah so as long as
you're close to it so we can have people
here um so we originally received 4.6
million in capital budget
um when the original estimates we the
original estimate was 4.6 Million by the
time we got to the capital budget
committee it had gone up to
5.2 um but what we ended up doing
instead is we received a million dollar
in a go for Grant through Dees to do a
feasibility study now earlier today you
heard about uh the committee that when I
came in as director I put together a
committee the governor appointed a
special committee to study the issue
that was step one step two was this
million feasibility study that
feasibility
study that's what Diane was referencing
when she said that they came up with hey
this going to cost probably $60 million
and oh by the way you may not be able to
meet 12 parts per billion every month at
which point we had to take a harder look
at the system and that's where we
decided to to move into um New Hampton
instead of New Durham for the complete
rebuild okay we'd like to maintain the
hatchery in New Durham uh at a much
smaller rate at that 30,00 000 we
believe we can meet the 12 part per
billion but the the the the volume and
the quality of the water in in at the
new Durham Hatchery is wonderful and we
rather not lose that well since this is
a policy committee and not a funding
committee I'm going to leave it at that
uh but I hope we can find the funding
for it because the policy is
sound good okay um thank you director
and and let's continue and and get back
on track Y no and so yeah the
construction manager just to just to tie
that in so the it enables us to work
directly have best estimates and best um
use in the design process as well as um
enable us to be fiscally responsible
because we're going to be able to talk
about pricing and materials and also
meet that supply chain um not worry
about the supply chain issue because we
can be talking things through in our
design so just just all around the board
enables us to be in a much better place
doing that um construction manager piece
design and then just some critical dates
and the um critical dates are February
that can this month we will be uh well
not we Department of Public Works will
be um releasing the RFQ for the
construction manager and then um in May
we'll be looking at getting that
information back from those folks that
did apply looking at the guaranteed
maximum price and a bidding for the
design at that point that um HDR will
have solidified and then uh August we
will have the GNC approval and at that
point the notice to proceed and um
really be able to move forward with this
effort and then
2025 um have our construction start and
um obviously in those time periods
during construction I think it's
important to note that obviously there
will be a reduction in fish because I
will have no place to put them so my
facilities are completely maxed at this
point and um at the end of 2025 we will
be 100% compliant at Powder Mill so I
can only have that 30% there and then um
our other facilities will be maxed so
there will be a reduction um during the
construction phase for sure but then in
2026 after we you know get everything
done and be able to start working
through the process and trainings and
whatnot um we'll be able to hopefully
get things back on
schedule okay I have one question um
sure do we have a federal EPA deadline
for our PPM coming out of our Fisheries
um that's been enforced on us or are we
good with these dates and are are we
going to be reducing the the uh fish
held at the Powder Mill in the meantime
as we're working towards this or are we
going to stay at full blast with the
full outflow and the parts per million
right up until we open the new
facility so the NEP permit is set at 12
parts per billion at new at New Durham
and so basically we have two hatcheries
that have single site nepes permits one
is New Durham and the other one is
Berlin the other four hatcheries come
under a general nepy's permit um and I
believe we have no limit on those four
correct correct all right so the only
two and we have no limit yet that it
hasn't been set yet at Berlin we we were
told they we're going to have the uh
we're in the rep permitting process at
burlin we were told they're going to be
done by October and they're still
working on it so I would be assuming
that we would be seeing something within
this calendar year from EPA as far as
setting a limit at
Berlin yeah thank you and thank you for
your presentation today just to add one
part to that so the December
2025 is the time period that we have to
meet new Durham's permit that's that one
does have a date that's good to know so
we're right up against the deadline on
that yeah and we we will be making
changes this year to our stocking to
reflect that okay thank you anybody have
any other questions before we move on
rep Smith thank you Mr chairman real
quick sure how many year facilities is
this a 50-year facility 75 what's the
pro so we have four facilities that are
over 100 one that's over 75 and the
other that's 53 so follow up yep it was
no the new facility that's going to be
built is there what's the expected
longevity of the new facility that's
going to be built we haven't asked for
an expected longevity uh with the
mechanical comp complications in the new
facility versus the old ones I would be
thinking you'd be having to have some
major reinvestment in probably the 30e
mark because of all the pumps and
whatnot it'll be in the new consider it
a
roof not a steel
roof any other questions representative
kofalt thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I'm looking
at the budget and I'm seeing a
contingency of
44% um this is sort of bottom right the
the 12 million
12,390 and then jump down a couple of
lines some Market volatility adjustment
and escalation to midpoint which sound
like
other other varieties of contingency
I've never seen a construction budget
with contingency numbers that high can
you just give us a quick explanation of
why we're seeing that so first of all um
you got to understand we are still in
the design phase so when an engineer
engineering firm has 10% of the design
phase done your contingency dollars is
much greater as the design gets more and
more completed then the contingency
they'll know more and more and then the
contingency drop drops quite often the
budget goes up as as more of this stuff
gets flushed out the other issue we're
facing and I think you you folks here
have seen it some of the other state
projects as we are in probably one of
the highest construction inflationary
periods that we've ever been in um there
was a bridge not too long ago that the
estimate was 40 million and the only bid
came back at I think close to $80
million to build so yes there is quite a
bit of float in here um but we are you
know first of all we won't waste money
secondly um we believe we can get it
done you thank you any further questions
before we let rep representative
ulette thank you and thank you for
taking my question uh 55 million how are
we paying for that this is all go for
money okay uh when um when I first came
on as director um we met with the
governor and he identified this as one
of the the issues that he wanted to
solve for the state and uh as Diane
mentioned earlier in our testimony today
what is it I can't remember the number
it's $4 billion dollars of tourist
dollars are spent in angling in New
Hampshire and I fudging 1.4 billion yeah
so it's a huge amount and um so it is
important to tourism um it's one of the
things you know when families are trying
to make up their mind where they go um
you know maybe more families are willing
to go to Story Land because Dad can get
an afternoon off to go trout fishing you
know that kind of stuff or you know
whatever the Dynamics are um it's it's
just one of those things it's not
necessarily a standalone event but it is
certainly something that you know
families do make decisions to come here
for yeah and if I could add the other
part key part here is that the water
quality at the end of the day is so much
better in these Raz facilities than they
currently are in ours so as um things
happen in our Hatchery currently it
starts at the top and it literally flows
through to the bottom and so now you'll
have that filtration you'll be able to
use less water in the recirculating
system so your treatment everything is
just much much better water quality wise
our discharge is actually going to be
better than it currently is so thank you
any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
presentation
today I will now reopen the hearing on
1100 if we can wheel the television out
to the side so that the audience can see
what's going on I'm going to call Kurt
erenberg from the Humane
Society Kurt you have written
testimony so pass it out and please
don't read from it you've asked for four
three and don't repeat your any previous
testimony if you've heard it already
please don't repeat it we already heard
it thank you Mr
chairman Vice chairman goalie members of
the committee I'm Kurt aronburg I'm of
the Humane Society of the United States
New Hampshire state director appreciate
the time I will be brief
um there is WR written testimony I don't
have it on paper I did submit it
electronically so I hope that can be
distributed
um I think this committee is is in a
position today to be reasonable in the
face of unreasonable cruelty which takes
place every spring in this state with
the killing of coyote mothers of pups
that then
suffer unnecessarily there's no
scientific reason for this I think
you'll hear this from others I would
just point out that the New Hampshire
Fish and Game department pointed out
itself that year round indiscriminate
killing of coyotes will not reduce their
populations in fact it encourages more
breeding and migration into the depleted
area and ultimately results in more
coyotes that's from the New Hampshire
fishing game department I have the
citation if you need it and I'm
done well thank you that was a minute
and 15 I maybe I won't hold people till
more than a minute in the
future uh are there any questions for
Kurt representative Darby and let me
remind representative Reed she's allowed
to take her seat she just can't start
with the questions okay I just didn't
want you standing for no reason uh after
presenting a bill we are allowed to go
back to our seat we just cannot
participate in the questioning uh so
representative Darby the floor is yours
um thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question just very briefly um
you said that you had the reference um
did you include that in your on in the
testimony you submitted yes thank you
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my
question so I've heard that the pup
season that's not true that the pups are
only managed by the parents for two
weeks and then they're out on their own
and so if what you're saying about
having the hunting season dur during the
pup season will impact that the
population is it a a two-e window or is
it a larger window is that an accurate
assessment that it's really only two
weeks and the pups are able to survive
on their
own you know I could answer that but I
think there are people here more
qualified to answer that and I think
that there are people from Vis and game
that could probably answer that thank
you uh but they did they you know the
citation I think you should look it up
again it's cruelty it's
unnecessary thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today
the chair will now recognize Fred
bird from
CSF that's the Congressional Sportsman
foundation and uh you got three minutes
very good thank you Mr chairman uh
honorable members of the committee uh
good afternoon once again uh I'm going
to try to hopefully take the emotion out
of what is a very emotional conversation
for both sides and CSF has opposed this
bill for the simple fact that the
rulemaking authority should be staying
with with the The Fishing Game
Commission and the department um that is
our concern the removal of that rule and
season setting authority of the
department and seaing it instead of the
legislator is problematic we have
professionals at the department they're
vetted they these people have gone
through school on the management side
law enforcement is vetted we got to
trust the professionals over there on
Hazen Drive um examples of this when our
Fisher population was in trouble the
Department adjusted That season they
were able to do that in real time if we
codify species specific season setting
with laws here in this body it's going
to be very cumbersome to go back and
adjust as we move forward as the science
changes I would agree with the bill
sponsor that we should be trusting the
science on the ground and as that
changes allow the department and the
commission to adjust uh we've done the
same thing with deer seasons in the
North Country we've adjusted the take
and when that season is conversely in
the South we've roduced M tags and L
tags to balance that that uh herd size
if the wildlife division Chief and the
very capable and qualified fur bear
biologists deem an adjustment in the
coyote season is needed we should allow
them to make that recommendation of the
commissioning move forward from that
that's all I have thank you so much
thank you you open to questions yes sir
please are there any
questions representative Darby thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um I I understand that
sometimes um coyotes are hunted with
dogs um can you describe um the process
of hunting coyotes with dogs are you
familiar with that I am I've never done
it myself or participated it's a
long-standing hounding tradition um
probably done by a handful of folks in
the state don't hold me to that because
I don't actually have facts uh perhaps
the the state can answer that for you
but that might actually be a better
question for fishing game because they
would have those
numbers
follow up um my my actual question was
on the process of hunting with with uh
dogs but if you think that would also be
better then I can hold
that well it's it's not part of the bill
uh to hunt with dogs or without dogs but
I mean peripherally it might be of
interest and I would probably hold that
game uh any other
questions seeing none thank you so much
you the chair now recognizes Joan
O'Brien representing herself supports
the bill and you'll get three
minutes thank you for coming in
today we appreciate you making the TR
way please turn the mic on when it's red
it's on thank you chair thank you
members of the committee my name is Joan
O'Brien I'm from Amherst I'm speaking in
support of the bill I have attended a
couple presentations by coyote expert
Chris shadler who was behind me and
testified so I I know a bit about um the
coyotes from her knowledge and um what
we don't realize is that most of us have
coyotes around us all the time there's a
there's a there's a a pack somewhere
within the vicinity of your house
because there's so many but how often do
we actually see them they find ways to
live among us and they're everywhere and
if they're left to do it their own way
they're
managed uh the every year in this
country people suffer from 4.5 million
dog bites we hear about coyote attacks
but the dog is a far greater threat to
coyotes and at the beginning of this
hearing somebody mentioned how often
this bill has come back to this
committee and I think that just speaks
to how important the issue is to us out
there who care about wildlife and don't
want these uncomfortable hunting methods
to
continue and lastly I don't know how
I'll just tell you a quick personal
story I live on land that backs up to
conservation land and on a spring night
shortly before dusk um I heard what I
thought was the distress calls of a
young animal in in the back of my
property and so I grabbed my coat and I
ran outside and I ran down to the woods
tracking the sound of this crying animal
to see if I could help and I arrived to
find sitting on a log a speaker was um
playing the sounds of like coyote pups
in distress and I was like what am I
looking at you know and then I looked to
the right and I saw two Hunters up in a
tree stand couple of young guys out on a
Friday night just sitting there calling
these coyotes and wanting to shoot them
testimony thank you for your time um I
guess there's no questions
um the chair now recognizes David
mtor Min
Minton I I got one diagonal line so I
was trying to make the best of it my
handwriting is great that's all right
you support the bill you'll get uh three
minutes but you've asked for two so you
get a
David my name is David Minon and I'm a
Hunter and I have lived and hunted in
New Hampshire for over 52
years during the past decades we have
all seen the loss of biodiversity in our
natural
world more flora fauna wildlife of All
Sorts is becoming endangered or extinct
every year and extinctions are on the
rise 21
species were declared officially extinct
in the United States last
year so why are we making it ever more
difficult for wildlife to coexist with
humans biological diversity in an
environment as indicated by a large
number of different species of plants of
animals is what we as a society should
strive
for it is our responsibility as humans
to see that we
share what little Wilderness we have
left on this planet with the wildlife
that we stole most of the Wilderness
from I personally
believe it is a plus that coyotes are
around and came into our environment
through natural means in New Hampshire
we have lost all of our major predators
and coyotes are filling the niche after
our forefathers wiped out the wolf the
mountain lion and other top predators we
need a wild Predator to make the system
function in the way it was supposed to
we need biological diversity for a
natural system to
function and don't try to convince the
public that coyotes are decimating the
deer herd you look at the annual deer
kill for the past 20 years it has gone
up tremendously from the 80s when many
of us
hunters would spend days or weeks out in
the woods without not much to show for
it back then the annual kill was around
4,000 to 6,000 deer a year now it hovers
around 12,000 to 14 14,000 and coyotes
have been in our state for over 50 years
and still the deer the annual deer kill
has gone up this is an animal which
displaced the wolf that was wiped out it
is taking its place in our natural
environment and we should allow nature
to take its course having a year- round
hunting season especially during the pup
season rearing season is inhumane and
unconscionable let us not forget what
happened when years ago fishing game was
proposing a trap and seasoning on the
Bobcat another animal that was making a
solid comeback into New
Hampshire we as a society must consider
the needs of Wildlife and as I've stated
earlier I a human being and a hunter
look for a healthy Lev you your three
minutes sir so wrap it up please of
biodiversity in our environment uh as I
said I'm a deer hunter and I welcome the
coyote and I urge the legislature to
approve and pass hb100 it is the morally
right thing to
do thank you so much will you take
questions sure are there any
questions representative
Brown thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question
um please take this I I'm being as
respectful as I can I'm not I want to so
I'm hearing you say that if we continue
hunting it could hurt the coyote
population where others this morning
have said if we have hunting during
pupping it will change the reproduction
process and create more coyotes those
seem to be two different things can you
speak to that yeah and and I'm not a
biologist by any means okay what what
I'm saying is you have an animal that's
made a comeback into our environment I
don't see why we have to put up
roadblocks no other animal that I'm
aware of is hunted during the pup season
it's inhumane it's not right
thank you yeah thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony today thank for the
time the chair recognizes Jim moris New
Federation you've asked for two minutes
well
sorry G to make noise uh good afternoon
uh chair uh members of the committee uh
my name is Jim Mo I'm the president of
New Hampshire Wildlife Federation uh I'm
speaking in behalf of a so affiliate
clubs and roughly 48,000 members uh and
Wildlife Federation um is the promoter
of hunting fishing trapping conservation
and the access to the land in the state
of New Hampshire
Hampshire Wildlife Federation strongly
opposes House Bill
place what did I
say oh sorry it's 1100 sorry about that
um
um the uh placement restrictions on the
uh hunting season is a dangerous
president uh we we look forward to
having fishing game biologists give uh
put seasons in place bringing it over to
the state legislation complicate some
matters and U Mr bird just spoke on that
and um each year the coyote population
seems to grow uh uh it more
confrontations
amongst residents pet
Wildlife
uh uh chickens sheep uh the Wildlife
Federation respects the work the fishing
game biologists do and we look forward
to their uh govering the uh seasons in
the scientific
dat thank you and I think we've all
gotten your written testimony so I
appreciate you not reading from it and
and uh giving us all the the scoop are
there any questions repes pres of Darby
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh you mentioned the um
coyot coyote population growing yeah um
I I looked at the um the latest report
from fish and game on um you know deer
numbers um turkey numbers um fur bearing
numbers it appears from what I can tell
that the only uh tracking they do of
coyotes is um is trapping as opposed to
hunting um so I'm just curious what uh
what the basis of the population growing
is well more encounters with the general
public and uh definitely roadkill um and
uh I think you'll see coming out uh
before long that there'll be more data
recovered from um hunting and of Road
kills uh down the
road representative goalie thank you Mr
chair isn't there also another way and I
know I've seen it quite often in areas
hunt and I think a lot of the folks in
your organization probably gather better
better data that on game cameras where
they never used to see coyotes before in
the deer yards that you're constantly
seeing pictures of coyotes that's
absolutely
true any further
questions anyone else seeing none thank
you so much for your
Dion representing the voices of Wildlife
life ask for 3 minutes and you'll get
three minutes okay thank you I was
wondering if I could give my time to
Chris shadler because she is the expert
I'm hearing a lot of false
information some we don't want to hear
uh from the same people who've already
minutes is this
on okay about it um k
being uh weaned you know the puppet two
weeks that's totally false if any of you
have ever had puppies the coyotes at
dogs you don't take the puppies away at
two weeks and and especially in the wild
that is not going to happen Okay so that
was totally false a couple people said
that even one of you repeated it you
know that's why you need the expert
Chris
shadler uh what else did I hear oh we
keep hearing the coyotes are multiplying
there's more coyotes than ever before
well we must be doing something wrong
don't you think if there's too many
coyotes this is not working what we're
working um oh I was a little bit
involved with a pesticide Bill last year
and uh the head of the pesticide board
he said that in the last 10 years he's
getting more rodent complaints than ever
before these carnivores like a coyote I
heard the Coyote's favorite food is a
mouse so we need these guys out there
and um cuz we all know about lime
disease and ticks that's all from the
little white footed mouse that the
coyote loves to
eat uh the other thing about this hiding
coyotes in these warm months the fur is
no good fishing game is fishing game
calls this want and waste of a natural
resource it is something fishing game
opposes
they're not going to eat the meat
they're not going to sell the fur the
coyote is just going to lie there
dead um on fishing games website they
also say this they say a coyote can be a
farmer's best friend if you um protect
your animals the the coyote will be your
best friend because he will eat the
Little Critters that are going to bother
your
vegetables uh I think that's about it I
I mean there's so much false information
you really need experts and another
thing we do respect the fishing game
biologists we really do and I have seen
fishing game biologists
propose um closing the hunting season
but they get old going to hear from one
in just a moment yeah well he won't
admit it because um he is govern ma'am I
won't allow aspersions being cast on
anyone so please I like the ERS on I
think he's wonderful he's a great
biologist let's keep things light happy
the reason they can't admit it is
because they're governed by the
commission whatever the commission says
that's what they have to say and the
commission as we know is a problem at
fishing game they just all hunters and
Trappers
and I've seen that I've seen biologists
overruled by the Commission in the past
one time they wanted to put limits on uh
foxes trapped
foxes um biologists wanted to do that
because they see the decline The Fishing
Game Commission would not allow it and
the fish commission call that's your
three minutes ma'am y thank you okay
question are you willing to take
questions sure why not thank you so
much rep car rep Brown thank you Mr
chair I don't know if this is a question
or a clarification or a point of order
information I wanted to be clear that
what you said that someone up here said
there is a two-e pup season I didn't
mean to say that I agreed with that or I
believe that I was asking a question
about it thank you okay thanks yeah my
apologies um I didn't even know it was
you I just heard somebody say okay thank
you any further
questions seeing none thank you so much
for your testimony the chair now
recognizes Dan berson biologist of
ficient
game who's asked for six minutes but
we'll get
enough
um good morning chairman Spain members
of the committee uh thank you for
allowing me to testify um I'm
representing the department my name is
Dan beron I'm the chief of the wildlife
division I'm representing New Hampshire
fishing game in opposition of
hb100 um so issues surrounding the
management of fur bearing species in
particular coyote um are are always
controversial um this was noted by our
commission um at our most recent bional
Ru making session we had a lot of
comments that came in regarding the
management of coyotes um even though we
had no proposals on the table um to
change any of the Season structures
around coyotes um because of the number
of comments that the department received
the commission had asked um biological
staff um at a later date to come up with
a presentation um and um future um
future things we could look at uh to get
a better idea of um what's going on with
the state's County population um the
department had done that and as a result
um what what we had proposed and what we
are looking to do um through the rule
making process will be to create a
mandatory uh registration process for
any fur bearing species that's that's
taken by hunting currently um virtually
all the information we have on fur
bearing species comes through an annual
trapping
report um that has been our longest
standing index um and way to track
changes in the population of fur bearing
species um there are there are a hand
full of fur bearing species that are
required to be reported fish is one of
them um if any fish are taken whether
it's hunting or trapping needs to be
sealed um but we tend to see very low
numbers that are taken during hunting on
species like that coyote arguably is
probably different um from surveys we've
done in the past we do we do believe
that there's likely more hunting
pressure on coyotes than um other fur
bearing species um that said um we we
don't have those specific numbers um
we've largely relied on this capture per
unit effort data um and that's how we
track changes in the population so
there's been a lot of um there's been a
lot of talk about knowing the number of
of any individual species in the state
quite frankly we don't know the number
of any of the species in the state um we
do have population models that will give
us information um um but even when we
have an estimate of of what the
population is what we're really looking
at is the trend in that population we're
not assuming um that those numbers are
are 100% accurate we know there's
there's variation in there and we're
interested in the trend and we get that
information through um what's called
capture perun effort information um
through mandatory trapping reports um
the information we have for coyotes
through our capture per unit effort data
shows that the states county population
over roughly the last 30 years has been
largely stable um again we don't know
the number of animals um but we know
that the population has been largely
stable based on capture perun effort um
which is an indication that current
season structures are not having an
negative impact on the population as a
whole um so our our current information
you're at your three minute Mark so
let's wrap it up thank you I just want
to be fair to everybody yeah and the
last thing I'll just mention is that um
it was mentioned before we are working
with UNH to do some camera trap research
to come up with additional ways to index
the the population um so for those
reasons um we would asked that the
department be able to retain its
rulemaking Authority on setting season
dates and timing um and allow us to
collect more
information thank you so much are there
any
questions rep
Ford thank you Mr chair um 30 years
stable um that's for New Hampshire can
you tell me any information if possible
about Maine and Vermont because they
seem to touch our border too so and I
would imagine coyotes don't just stay in
New Hampshire um so what did that what
do those Trends look like yeah so I'm
not I'm not sure specifically of what
they've seen for long-term trends uh my
guess is it would be very fairly similar
to what we've seen um certainly coyotes
are a gous species they've expanded
their range um um you'll see annual
fluctuations that might go up and down
quite a bit a lot of that is due to you
know natural food ability things like
that um so you know again we're looking
at very long-term trends in this so and
this is at Large Scale so our estimate
for coyotes in particular is at a
Statewide level um things can vary quite
a bit you know throughout the the range
of coyotes so you could have certain
areas of the state where you know for
some portion of time you might see an
increase other areas might be declining
but generally speaking on a Statewide
level our coyote population based on the
information we currently have has been
stable thank
you uh representative uh PE sorry thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question couple things as a biologist
pull the mic closer so that the YouTube
people might be able to hear that hello
test test test okay um we've heard a
couple of things about the bi basic
biology of coyotes the reproductive um
mechanisms of them and this business of
well they they only mind their pops for
two weeks and and that's the end of it
would you care to add a professional
comment on either of these
items um certainly
so yeah so two weeks um so pups start to
leave the den after about two to three
weeks they're weaned um roughly
around um you know it varies we haven't
done any specific research in New
Hampshire but they're we weaned probably
around 7 to 8 weeks um they stay with
you know the the juveniles start to
disperse around 6 to 8 months so um two
to two to 3 weeks is certainly short if
you're talking about how long the pups
are actually with the adults um so that
but they're that's typically when
they'll start to leave the
den oh so is it fair to say that EXC
followup oh sorry followup you were
granted a followup thank you is it fair
to say that they're learning pack
Behavior Uh or adult Behavior over that
eight-week period before they start
dispersing to other things on their own
I think it would be fair to say that the
time that the pups are with the adults
they're learning from the adults um um
pack behavior um not all coyotes do run
in packs but but certainly the time
they're with the adults they learn that
and that's true for most Wildlife deer
is a good example um fawns when they're
with the with the Doe's have learned
behaviors as
well and and and followup again well
this is sort of a re rework but I uh it
would have to be another followup if you
were at all right well we'll call it a
followup then you get another followup
thank you sir thank you um I had also
asked about the um um uh their um mating
behaviors and the size of litters and so
forth yeah so um so largely what's
what's seen is less behavioral and more
a result of um access to additional
resources and that's again that's seen
in um really most Wildlife species deer
is another good example if you have a
very high deer population um that is
near the carrying capacity of the
habitat or um it's it's essentially
using up all the resources that the
habitat has available if you reduce that
population that opens up resources and
you'll see an increase in productivity
in that in that deer population as well
and that's largely what's seen in
coyotes as well um so again that
response will largely be dependent on
what's limiting the population um so if
they're not food limited um you you may
not see that response and again um given
the season framework that we've had in
New Hampshire um we have not seen any
increase um any sort of drastic increase
in the Cy population again you know
fluctuations annually but the
stable thank you representative
Harvey thank you Mr chair I did it right
this time uh and thank you for taking my
question um so she started the question
so I guess I'm just doing a follow up to
hers um would you say that the
reproduction of the coyote is
if you had to compare responsive
reproduction and the food source which
do you think would most um affect the
number of young the coyote have I think
at a population level I think food
availability thank you uh representative
wette then representative
goalie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question thank you as
I'm sitting here uh couple things go
through one mind um we all uh understand
the Natural Balance of animal population
and stuff and as I'm sitting here um is
the coyote in New Hampshire the only fur
bearing animal that does not have a
natural
predator
sorry um that is pro uh fur bearing
true okay uh representative goalie thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question youve stated that the
population is
stable could you expound upon that a
little bit because from what I'm seeing
and hearing from other people in the
woods they're seeing more and more
pictures of coyotes on cameras and
encounters is stable mean that it's
sustainable and or is it it hasn't
population hasn't increased over the
last 5 years it hasn't decreased or we
just don't know and it's hard to tell um
so again our numbers are pretty General
on a Statewide level um we don't have so
um so species like deer and other things
where we get a lot of information um at
the management unit level which is
typically an aggregate of multiple towns
um we can say more precisely at smaller
scales with those popul ations are doing
for for most fur bearing species and
coyote in particular um we really only
have confident numbers at a Statewide
level so um you know again it it there
could be certain areas of the state
where there's you know temporary
increases declines but from a Statewide
level um we have not seen what we would
call a dramatic increase in the overall
number of coyotes at a Statewide um now
certainly um
in terms of people's observations I
always caution to be careful about
individual observations we do use some
observational data but we try to uh the
method we collect that information we
try and standardize it so it's
comparable from um across different
areas from year to year um so one of the
reasons that people might start to see
more things is there's a lot more
cameras in the woods um Technologies
increase so they capture things more
readily um that's not the say that there
might not be local areas where there's
something going on that's caused an
increase in that specific area but again
from a Statewide level um are our
information indicates that there's not
been any significant increase in the
coyote
population follow
up just one quick followup yep because
as you know as you stated there's more
and more cameras in the
woods is fishing game at any time going
to start reaching out to those who are
in the woods viewing the pictures what's
going on the most contact cover more
Woods than anybody in the state and look
for the information that they're
receiving on their cameras to get real
time information to help out with the
Department on their numbers so we do
have um we do have some Hunter surveys
where we'll get sighting rates from
hunters and again um those are
structured in a way that are
standardized so it's sent out to the
same number of people every year um and
we you know we get number of hours
number of individuals scene um from the
camera perspective we have and I I kind
of lost um ran out of time but we're
currently working with the University of
New Hampshire to use trail cameras um to
index different Wildlife populations fur
bears but also Mose um potentially other
things in the future um and again the
the problem with just getting
um the the cameras need to be set up in
a very specific way um and monitored in
a specific way um to make the
information comparable and usable so um
you know where you know um we try and
Scatter it across multiple types of
habitat they're all set at the same
height they're checked at the same
intervals um there's um there are
markings so that we can tell distances
that animals cross in front of it so
it'd be difficult to get information
from the general public and have it be
uh usable um to come up with some sort
of population
estimate followup thank you and just one
quick last followup because in talking
about the surveys that you send out and
correct me if I'm wrong I believe the
last one I received didn't have any
reporting for coyotes is that
true um that's yeah it would I'd have to
go back and check the S so we we got a
number of surveys um coyotes is not one
that would you typically get the Deer
Hunter survey that's not asked on that
correct and can we add
it um we we potentially could um we did
I believe we added coyotes to our spring
turkey hunter
survey okay any other questions rep
Darby thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um with respect to um you know fishing
game setting Seasons um can you talk
about how
um the the principles of fair Chase as
um espoused by you know Teddy Roosevelt
are really started the conservation
movement and and currently supported by
organizations um like the Boon and
Crockett Club um are um incorporated
into setting of those
Seasons um yeah
so um we we try to incorporate Fair
Chase as best we can um Fair Chase
um Fair Chase is a social aspect of of
what we do um we try and make decisions
largely based on science um social
issues always creep in um the problem is
that there are certain methods um where
there is debate on whether or not it's
fair Chase um many methods that are
considered Fair chase by group such as
Boon and Crockett are not considered
Fair chase by other groups so um it
becomes very difficult um to try and
capture you know methods that every
different constituency group that that
has a um interest in this consider Fair
Chase um Bai baiting is an example um
you know there are certain um there are
certainly conservation organizations
that consider those methods Fair Chase
there's a large member of the group of
the public that do not so it it's It's
tricky because there's a lot of varying
viewpoints on what is considered Fair
Chase we do our best um to incorporate
what we believe is Fair Chase but again
it's the the people's viewpoints on that
widely thank you any other questions
representative
Brown
um you lost it I have
one um anecdotally we we hear from
Hunters a lot that they see a lot more
coyotes um I've mentally Cor corelated
this with the increase in the Turkey
population uh would you be able to
expound to us on whether turkeys are a
natural uh food source for the coyotes
and whether the extremely successful
Rebound in the Turkey population has had
any impact on the coyote population as
well as the other Predator populations
whereas we've seen the uh rebound on the
Bobcats as well and such like that sure
um so um turkey's absolutely are a food
source for coyotes um coyotes are a
generous species so virtually everything
is a food source for coyotes um you know
acorns people love to talk about how
turkeys eat the acorns that the deer
should be eating everything eats acorns
so you know it's I always find it
interesting when people say you know um
certain food sources is kind of reserved
for an individual species um because
again um most species eat a variet of
things so um I would say absolutely
turkeys are a food source for coyotes um
deer fawns are um small mammals they eat
fruits they eat nuts um I'll also state
that we've seen um you know stable to
increase in CI population increasing
Turkey population increasing deer
population um stable to increasing bear
population depending on the the portion
of the state you're you're talking about
so we've seen a number of species all
increasing um at the same time and and
you'd mentioned it as well anecdotally
more than anecdotally Bobcats as well so
we've seen an increase in a number of
these species um we don't have any
indication that um really any of them
are having State at a Statewide level a
negative impact on the other at this
point um if depending on the species
you're talking about um but again we've
seen increases in all those species um
at the same
time thank you and I I have another
question before we get to everyone else
because I was waiting for everyone else
for so long um when it comes to uh
determination of
Seasons I have been on this committee
for 10 years five terms in the house uh
I've been a hunter for far many more
than that and I'm not going to get into
details because I don't want to date
myself although no one else will so I
might as well um the when it comes down
to the fishing game setting season
and listing species as managed species
it's my understanding that it's done on
one criteria
scientifically and not others the one
criteria being will this species be
harmed irreparably or suffer detriment
if we don't have a season and don't have
uh them listed as a managed species for
bag limits or such um we don't typically
take into account is it
cute is it having babies if those were
qualifications I think we'd never hunt
bunnies because they're constantly
having babies and they're always cute
would you speak to the scientific
determination that determines whether
something is a managed species or has a
season or bag limit set for it
please um yeah so generally speaking the
main criteria is whether or not there's
a there the population can be
sustainably Harvest harvested um so so
certainly um again most of our name
species have high reproductive potential
um you know they're they're not limited
by habitat or other things like that um
so that is certainly the main criteria
once a species is managed then we start
to consider other factors where you have
that Liberty but um that's certainly the
main factor on whether or not to include
a species as a managed species thank you
represent
Ford thank you Mr chair um chief that it
my question is not uh combative I just
want to know and you can pass this on to
I guess the Commissioners but 10 years
with this particular coyote thing and
today I've heard a lot of things that
this keeps coming up and um the two
sides debate whether or not it should be
codified or keep it in the rules but
clearly the rules aren't working because
it keeps coming up so I guess my
question is when will the Commissioners
and the what is stated in your letter
here the ability to place rules wait
wait where was it or like the ability to
set rules so when are we're going to get
a rule about coyotes we're going to get
a rule about all these other different
things that we are saying leave it to us
to set the rules but here we are 10th
year of the same bill coming forth
either the Commissioners and the fish
and game department doesn't believe
there should be a rule on coyotes or
you're just choosing not to set a rule
because you don't want to set a rule on
coyotes which I would just like to know
know the answer to that yes absolutely
so um so this this question is largely
um it's not a biological question
because again all of our information
suggests that the population is is
healthy and stable um so therefore you
have to base it on um you know again
we're weighing input from a vast array
of people who are um who are a
constituents so um you know some would
have us do nothing some would have us
get rid of it Al together um so it's
difficult to make those decisions when
you're you're you're really not doing it
for a biological reason um because again
we have no reason to believe that the
the coyote population is in Jeopardy
from a population level
perspective follow up that's what I was
hoping you would say so how long will it
take for us to get scientific biological
data on coyotes in the state of New
Hampshire if we're partnering with UNH
and we're looking at the we're getting
Trapper information to surveys how long
will this take and will I have to wait
another 10 years before yeah so so the
trapping information we have um roughly
30 years worth of that on what the trend
in the population is um we've seen a
decline in the number of Trappers in the
state um so as the numbers decline your
sample size gets smaller so then the
data that you get you know you start to
question is it still valid that's why
we've um partnered with UNH um to do
this camera research to come up with an
additional index um to track some of
these populations where where our sample
sizes are smaller again there's you know
there's 50 to 60,000 hunters in the
state that provide us information on
something like a white tail deer there's
there's likely nowhere near that for a
lot of these other species so um we have
to come up with alternate ways to to
find that information um anytime you
start to collect new information
particularly Trend information it takes
at least a few years um to you know one
one point on the map tells you virtually
nothing um so you know we we would it
would be at least a few years worth of
data I think before we felt comfortable
now it depends what questions being
asked as well so um you know with
mandatory registration um we'll start to
get the number of people that do this at
different times a year how many animals
they're taking and that at the very
least would give us an idea of um um you
know under current structures um when
are the bulk of these animals taking
place so if you were to shorten things
at this end or that end um is there
going to be big impact no impact you
know again we'll be speaking in general
terms but you know after a couple years
we'd probably have that type of
information thank you and representative
Darby thank you Mr chair um just
following up on the the last two
questions um can you um can you describe
the reason um then for the the fox
there's a fox season um a closed Fox
season and not a closed um closed coyote
season um it's likely it's likely
largely um historical um when coyotes
because again coyotes um coyotes are
somewhat more of a recent um species in
the state of New Hampshire um they also
are there's biologically a lot of
differences between productivity rates
of coyotes and foxes coyotes are a
generalist species um they have higher
reproductive potential um so that alone
would would necessitate some differences
in the season structure um some of it
might be again you know historically
that's what the seasons were um again
long-term looking at the data there's
nothing to indicate that the current
season structur is having a negative
impact on the population um but you know
and there's you'll see that you I mean
some even within an individual species
sometimes we'll have varying Seasons
from one part of the state to the next
variation thank you any other
questions
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
again so
mind okay not too much keep
writing any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you so much for your testimony that was
the last pink card we had so I will now
close the hearing on
hb100 thank you very
up I don't want to leave you out ma'am
minutes get ready to start your timer
that um I'm actually not going to speak
for 3 minutes because I submitted
written testimony my name is BJ wall I
live in Sullivan which is near Keen um
the only thing I do want to say and I I
do hope you read my written testimony is
that when I went online this morning and
looked at all of the online submissions
there were well over 200 people in
support of this bill and there were
seven people opposed to it and if this
committee and the legislature in general
is truly
supposed to represent the people then I
feel like you have no choice but to
support this bill because it's clearly
overwhelmingly the will of the people
that this bill be passed that's all I
need to
say thank you are there any
questions okay seeing none thank you for
your testimony and now I will close the
hb100 we can take a five minute break uh
expect people can caucus if they want to
moments
hb100 that's what jamy brought
out that that's good I got so I will
tell you that
uh as of this morning we had on HB 1100
online uh 211 in support seven opposed
zero neutral just
numbers and on our signin sheet we have
1 two 3 4 five 6 7 eight people in favor
1 two 3 four five 6 7 8 9 10 people
opposed
and I'm going to uh look to rep ulette
to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move that
we um itl HB
seconded any
discussion representative Darby thank
you Mr chair I believe that um Fishing
Game Commission should be um The
Authority for setting um for setting uh
hunting and fishing um dates and Seasons
that being said I'm very um I personally
oppose and I think that my constituents
personally would also oppose um the
hunting of uh coyotes by with dogs which
is a very small population I know during
um the critical P bearing um phase
especially especially Denning but even
the uh first few weeks after Denning so
I'll be uh I'll be supporting the itail
motion but I surely hope that uh The
Fishing Game Commission can consider um
what I would consider ethical rules um
of of uh Denning um Denny mothers that
uh Denning coyote mothers that protect
hunting rights as well in the future
thank you representative Darby I I think
I will mention to you that there's a
bill in the Senate I believe uh
regarding hunting with dogs but this
bill does not address any of the dog
issue um any other discussion on the
bill representative
Ford thank you Mr chair I um I
appreciate this bill I just it's one of
those things where um as a newbie um to
the legislature and also to this
committee to hear that something has
come up multiple times um in
understanding like to hear this next
year and the year after because you know
constituents and folks on the committee
May um want this type of thing and so um
I appreciate the conversation that we're
having about this and um I'm starting to
lean toward letting the rules uh the
rules folks create the rules but at some
point we have to um we have to do
something and I don't want to be another
10 years of data collection and research
and all these things where um or use of
cameras or survey usage and things like
that um but I I think I I think I will
be supporting the it on this particular
bill just based on conversation or
hearing that the division the department
will be working on collecting data
having data for us in regards to Coyote
so that next session we don't hear we
need to pass something without having
data so I would like to have the data
for that thank you representative Harvey
um so being the per one of the one of
the members of this committee that
actually goes to fishing game
um I can tell you uh representative Ford
the coyote question was uh debated and
um two Commissioners actually voted uh
to um Institute some sort of season so I
I think that um the the commission is
hearing
us is hearing us
thanks any further discussion on
this representative goalie
thank you Mr chair and I will be
supporting the itl um I do believe that
season setting belongs in rules and this
is going down a slippery slope putting
this into statute um and I also you know
believe that you know hearing the way
things are going right now with no
reporting requirements we don't even
know if there's 1 5 10 15 coyotes killed
during this period of time during this
hunting season going on now the
department is going to do something
about it they're going to require
reporting we'll get the data we can find
out what's going on and see where what's
happening with this but until we have
that data I think it's not right to move
forward with this and hopefully they
keep this coyote reporting on the muzzle
loader and deer archery Hunter survey
that goes out because some of us didn't
see it on the last
one any other questions conversation
representative
Reed thank you um just this year alone
this committee has passed unanimously
putting things that have always been in
rules only in rules into statute this
particular issue hasn't come before the
legislature more than twice I introduced
it in 2019 and now I'm introducing it
now but it has become come before the
commission over and over and over and
over again and it's the culture of the
commission that's the issue and it's our
job to actually reign in any for
whatever committee to reign in the
department when the department is is
going against its own mission the
mission of the department I will read
very briefly by the
way in addition to other duties provided
by law shall be the duty of the Fish and
Game Commission as the citizens
representatives to be the stewards of
the Fish Wildlife and Marine Resources
of the State of New Hampshire and to set
General policy in the following areas
and the area that is most pertinent is
the first which is conservation
protection and management of wildlife
populations and habitats the collection
of necessary scientific information and
the enforcement of fish and game laws
for the purpose of sustaining healthy
populations of Fish Wildlife and Marine
Resources and we've seen the culture of
this particular commission go against
that over and over and over so after all
of these years and all of these attempts
it is our job to step in like we did
with the caliber of uh of bullets for
example so yeah we I think we have to do
point any further comments Jeff
represented goalie thank you Mr chair
and as we talk about the mission of
fishing game I believe they are being
true stewards because I have not heard
of any reduction
or serious decline in the coyote
population nor is it in Jeopardy of
going that way thank
you representative Reed and I don't want
this to become a debate so let's go
ahead and make our comments then we can
leave it at two and two then um so as we
talked about as many people testified to
including the state's best experts on
coyote coyote engage in responsive
reproduction so that would explain very
well why the populations have remained
stable what hasn't remained stable is
the interactions between coyote and
humans and the reason that hasn't
remained stable is because the coyote
become nuisance coyote when they are
forced to go out into the wild without
proper guidance as to what their the
correct food sources are and that's
what's happen happening when we hunt
them indiscriminately year
round any further comments before we
take the role representative Ford I just
have a question shair um question of the
chair of like can I ask representative
Reed a question yeah like we're having
discussion go for it but this is not
going to become a debate okay no no it's
a um I guess my question
is knowing what it what this bill is
about would you be okay with the fish
and game department collecting data to
say this is the this is how many coyotes
we have or this is projection of what we
have and this is what we know of for the
baby making period I don't know what
it's called natural world um but this is
the period and this is the time that we
would set forth if we wanted to have a
freeze on Hunting of coyotes would you
be okay with them having that period of
time to give us the data if do doesn't
make sense when I'm asking are you
asking for a moratorium on coyote
hunting while they collect the data is
that you set a freeze no no no no no no
no no no no no no I know what committee
I'm on I'm not GNA be calling for that
hunting okay um to answer your question
I think as I heard your question you can
correct me if I if I didn't understand
correctly am I in favor of the
department collecting data yes the
Department's job as I just read is to
collect scientific data we do not fund
those particular activities at the
levels that need to be done for coyote
or any other species we don't give them
what they need to collect the scientific
information to do appropriate um to
collect appropriate data and and um and
give us what what we really want out of
the department so is that going to
change are we going to change this into
a funding bill so we can fund that data
collection and if that's not going to
happen then I really struggle to
understand what additional information
we're going to get if we're not going to
fund that data collection that we
fund all right any other questions
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the
role representative
goalie
yes representative KH yes representative
Smith yes representative kofalt yes
representative Tor yes repres
resentative Brown yes representative
Corran is absent representative Hill yes
representative wette yes representative
abar yes representative Harvey
no representative
Reed no representative
Ford
no representative Fox
no representative
rung yes
representative schliff
yes representative
PE reluctantly yes representative Rosner
no and representative Derby yes and
chairman Spain
yes I have 14 yes and five
no I passes and it will not be on
consent uh is there is there a Minority
representative Reed I need a Minority
Report before noon
tomorrow and a majority report will be
Mike is yours going to be a
recommendation of
OTP he has to record OTP um minorities
uh majority
itl minority
OTP um
Reed and
ulette okay uh the next bill we're going
to go ahead and do is uh one that was
held from last year HP 1530 I'll open
the executive session on 1530 FN
uh in discussions with the prime sponsor
to bring us uh an amendment that matched
what we heard in committee would
possibly be the amendment uh he said
that more work was needed on the bill so
at this point I will take uh a motion
from uh representative
ulette thank you Mr chairman I make the
motion for uh interim study we have
interim study moved and and uh do I have
a second second it's been moved and
seconded do we have any discussion on
1530 seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
role uh representative goalie yes
representative Khan yes representative
Smith yes representative kofalt
he's gone
sorry representative tutor yes
representative Brown yes representative
Coran is
absent representative Hill yes
representative wette yes representative
AAR yes representative Harvey I'm sorry
yes representative Reed yes
representative Ford yes representative
Fox yes representative rung yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative
peer yes representative Rosner yes
representative Derby yes and chairman
Spain yes
180 consent okay with
consent
and Mike we might need a small blurb for
that in case it gets pulled off
consent 18
zero yeah um we have one absent and rep
coalt stepped
uh for
1417 well trout
that here it is right on top thank you
and
online Okay so the numbers online for
1417 56 in support for
oppose and the blue sheet for signin
today was 1 2 3 four to nine uh four to
nine four for for the bill and nine
opposed and I'm going to look to uh
representative a for a motion yes thank
you Mr chairman I make a motion to itl
HB
okay do I have a second I'll second that
Mr chair it's been moved and seconded do
we have any discussion on hb1
1417 yes sir uh Mr chairman I uh put
forth an itl motion based on the fact
that fishing game already has a vehicle
for trout management and we do not need
to codify this in New Hampshire
statute thank you is there any further
discussion seeing none oh oh
representative Reed thank you I disagree
that we don't need to codify it because
the department has not added any Waters
in 20 years because the department's
website has I guess mysteriously um the
information about the program has
disappeared uh the bill as written gives
the department great leeway as to how
they manage that program and what Waters
to include or take off to grow the
program and even shrink the program um
but what is clear is the department has
not taken this program for years very
seriously I do hope that that will
change but um this has been an issue
that has been brought to them repeatedly
and they've repeatedly promised they
would do something about it and as of
not thank you any further
comments seeing none the clerk will call
the
role
1417 uh representative goalie yes
representative Khan yes representative
Smith
yes representative tutor yes
representative Brown yes representative
Hill yes representative wette yes
representative abar yes representative
Harvey yes representative Reed no
representative Ford no representative
Fox
yes representative rung yes
representative schliff yes
representative PE yes representative
Rosner yes representative Derby yes and
chairman Spain
yes 16
three that shouldn't be three that
should be two uh 162 2 plus one is three
no it's just two never
mind
162 uh everybody okay with
consent all right uh we will need a
potential majority blur for consent
calendar if you'd like to write that up
uh representative a bear just in case we
um we need it let's go to 1148 exec
session for 1148 open
now this is relative to The Fish and
Game
Commission representative AAR AAR I'll
meent I'll recognize you for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
make a motion for interim study of HB
1148 do we have a
second I've got Mike down with his hand
quicker than you but thank you as the
prime sponsor that really means a lot uh
who was that ulette seconded it and
Harvey second no Harvey was going to
Second it which was which was very
thoughtful as the prime sponsor a bear
was first Harvey was second is that you
can I mean either one let's let you know
what she's the prime sponsor let her
have the second that's fine absolutely
fine thank you Mr chair chairman you're
very welcome I just was seeing a hand
before yours and figured I'd go with the
first hand but I think it's really
meaningful um so let me give you the
numbers
1148 uh 7 support seven oppose one
neutral I didn't even know how you could
put a neutral on line but it is it is a
thing uh sign in on the blue sheet with
zero in favor and 12
opposed and the motion is interim study
does anybody have any comments on this
Mr chairman I feel strongly that HB 1148
was recommended for interim study by its
prime sponsor and therefore I recommend
that thank you any other input on this a
prime sponsor want to say
anything I I think it's the right
decision I I hope that when we have an
interim study it's a legitimate interim
study and we really do look at the
question and see if we can come to some
sort of um consensus so that we don't
have to see this this bill you know in
the 20 2425 session again so as long as
we can have a a real sitdown with all of
the um parties involved I'm okay with it
thank
you representative Brown you may call
the
role representative goalie yes
representative Khan yes representative
Smith yes representative tutor yes
representative Brown yes representative
Hill yes representative wette yes
representative abar yes representative
Harvey yes representative Reed no excuse
me representative Ford
yes representative Fox yes
representative rung yes representative
shirtliff yes representative pear yes
representative Rosner yes representative
Derby yes and chairman Spain yes okay 17
+ 1 is 18 17 to
one and wait a minute
uh kofalt was back for this oh sure you
tell me that I have him absent
representative kofalt yes move consent
please 18 to1 18 to1 and it's been moved
consent anybody have an objection to
that consent it is and uh I will allow
you to write a small blur for us thank
you a bear uh we are now on HB
1029 exec session opens
up
41029 uh I'm going to recognize a
Jonathan for a motion thank you
represent Smith sorry I motion ought to
pass on House Bill 1029 do I have a
second on that
tutor representative Smith you're free
to speak now or offer amendments as such
thank you Mr chair uh every there was an
amendment passed out number
0519 everyone should have it in front of
them this amendment addresses the
concerns that were inuring testimony
regarding uh the manner of taking it now
says any legal legal mean so you can't
misconstrue that you took it in an
illegal fashion and bring it to Shore
and the also concern was that New
Hampshire um excuse me that Maine and
Massachusetts residents would benefit
this this clarifies it also that it only
applies to New Hampshire residents so
those were the two big concerns that
were presented and I think this bill
clarifies that and uh excuse me this
amendment clarifies that and uh it makes
it my mind
passable representative
chair I don't believe it still fixes the
problem we heard that
Hampshire could not take now we've
introduced the amendment we're going to
take a vote on the amendment who M will
someone who m a boat in another state
could not I could not take the lobsters
into Maine and not have to be required
to a uh get a landing permit and also
the same thing went on
for folks who brought their catch into
Massachusetts so this doesn't solve that
issue also the issue goes
to reporting requirements that are
required by the Atlantic marine
fisheries this goes around that
reporting as well that is required for
the states to do up and down the East
Coast um this takes that reporting away
and for for that reason I cannot support
this
thank you representative Harvey um I I
won't be supporting this bill either as
we heard more and more testimony I just
kept getting more and more confused but
more and more confused on a higher level
I guess um and I don't think that this
answers the the questions that were
posed this morning in fact I think I
heard at one point a statement that was
made so we're being asked to pass a bill
that's basically illegal and um so I
won't be supporting this
yes
any further
comments representative Khan thank you
Mr chairman uh Mr chairman uh we heard
the testimony this morning from multiple
fishing industry uh uh
representative uh also the fish and game
uh representative and their written
testimony states that um how big this
industry is and how much they are
helping our niham economy for many years
and uh in order to touch this uh
industry we have to be very careful that
how we can affect negatively so
therefore you know after listening after
for me coming from SE Coast I cannot
support this uh uh this bill I
appreciate U uh representative Hill to
bring the amendment and bring the bill
his intention is good he's my good
friend he answered very hard questions
but still I cannot support this Bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you any fur
representative Darby thank you Mr chair
I would like to uh reinforce
representative Khan's um comments that
the commercial fishing industry came
against it they are facing a lot of
pressure as the um new regulations are
being um passed um on Commercial
lobstering and uh the reporting
requirements are more important than
ever and as we heard from uh fishing
game this will really um go around the
reporting requirements for the um uh for
the um recreational angles thank you
thank you any further
comments we are on the
amendment representative
goalie thank you Mr chair and I just you
know we heard
about the price for non-resident
licensing and
that is an exorbitant amount and I would
hope at some point we can address that
and bring it down a little bit so that
folks can afford this um but other than
that that's I think about the only
change that really needs to be
addressed thank you before I forget I'm
going to read the numbers from online
and such uh
1029 to support for oppose online and in
the uh blue sheet One support and five
oppos and we are on the amendment we're
not on the bill yet just the amendment
so if you believe the amendment makes
the bill better that's what we're on uh
I will ask the clerk to call the
9h representative
goalie no representative Khan no
representative Smith yes representative
kofalt yes representative tutor yes
representative Brown yes representative
Hill
yes representative Willet yes
representative abar yes representative
Harvey no representative Reed
no representative Fox no representative
rung no Representative schliff no
Representative peir no representative
rosener
yes representative Derby
yes 11 yes 8 no so the amendment passes
and we're on
otpa is there any discussion on the bill
as otpa at this point I know a lot of
the discussion on the amendment was
actually on the underlying bill but uh
I'm flexible that
way and so seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call oh representative goalie
thank you Mr chair and I will just
reiterate we are not complying with the
um Atlantic State Fisheries um
requirement
of the uh marking down on the catch here
in New Hampshire if we go by passing
this thank you and remind me to always
go for a gunfight against you CU you're
draw the clerk will now oh wait a minute
we've got a rep Ford as well recognize
for your comment thank you I I'm sorry
I'm also slow on the draw so you would
definitely win in a gun fight but um I
guess I'm I guess the amendment and now
the bill any legal
means
what outside jurisdiction of the state
right so we're talking about main Waters
massachusett Waters in federal waters
right I I guess I'm trying to
understand what what will this bill do
pro outside of like reaffirming that you
could just lie about whether or not
you're going to sell the lobsters or
keep the lobsters to yourself because
it's basically saying if you go to any
other waters outside of New Hampshire
and catch these lobsters including
Federal and I pretty sure you have to
have a license to do the skin diving for
lobsters as well right with the Federal
no so you can go federal waters you're
allowed to die for lobster with no no uh
no license great so you go do that and
then you're you come back maybe you will
sell them maybe you I it just seems like
this bill doesn't
necessarily need to happen maybe we talk
about the fees but yeah I'm just so to
answer the you asked something about the
any legal means that was because it said
before any means which which would have
meant that potentially you could go out
and poach them and still bring them back
by the amendment says any means to make
that if they're caught in Massachusetts
they have to legally caught in
Massachusetts if they're caught in Maine
they have to be legally caught in Maine
if they're caught in federal waters they
have to be legally caught in federal
waters which also uh imposes the size
limits and everything else for those
Waters um and currently you cannot die
for lobsters in Maine so those would be
trapped lobsters in Maine but you can
dive for lobsters in Mass so it could
have been trapped or yeah uh dive for
them uh I don't know about crabs in
Maine crabs are okay in Maine for diving
I don't know uh crabs are able to be you
can dive for them in in mass and here uh
so so you know it's basically saying if
if you're following the law that's what
legal means means so I just want to
clarify that because you did have the
question on legal means yeah no and that
see slow on the draw should have been a
question during the amendment portion
discussion so that's fine fine that's
what we here for an exact session is
when we can ask we can challenge I just
don't want debates right we don't want
to break down into that type of a
situation representative Harvey because
goalie has already spoken a couple of
times okay but that that doesn't um
alleviate the
um that we are bypassing the um the
statute that says we need to report and
it also doesn't um it does open the door
that people could say oh I'm I'm not
selling these lobsters and then go home
and ask your neighbor you know I have a
lobster can I give $ five doar for it so
I I will be opposed to the bill although
I think the amendment made it better I'm
going to throw in my comment because the
the lying has come up a couple of times
you really can't stop someone from lying
at any time like um for example I could
be out on the street selling drugs and
they could stop me and say what are
these for and I could say personal
use
when you're bringing in the fish catch
um you could certainly go and say I'm
bringing in but at some point there's a
quantity right if I'm bringing back four
lobsters it's very reasonable that
they're for personal use if I'm bringing
back 20 it's probably not unless I'm a
glutton uh so I think that law
enforcement has some pretty good Clues
as to some whether someone's lying or
not in that kind of situation and I'll
leave my argument at that point um if
someone's going to break the law they're
going to break the law our job is to to
try to make it better for people who are
not breaking the law so they don't
unintentionally break the law or so that
they have an easier time to uh to do the
things that they enjoy without breaking
the law and representative Smith thank
you Mr chairman I have a procedural
question because it's been brought up
repeatedly that this if this became law
would bypass the reporting requirements
is there any way in rules or possibly a
floor amendment to make it where
there still is a reporting requirement
even though you're coming to shore for
your own personal use that it still has
to be reported I'm sure because the
intent of this was only to remove the
fee for a landing license I don't think
that there'd be any prob problem with
putting a reporting requirement on
bringing them ashore um I don't know
whether that would be something rules
related and I would be willing to call
up Colonel Jordan to answer whether
that's something that can be handled in
rules if the committee would like to
hear from him uh but he may not know it
might be something that has to be looked
into before we can get an answer
um at the very least a floor Amendment
could do it or an amendment in the
Senate uh if we wanted to make sure the
reporting Amendment gets on to it uh
representative Hill I don't think as
I I don't think that there was a uh in
this in this section of the statute
there was anything about the um
reporting that was necessary or that was
included you weren't here for the whole
testimony over the correct correct and
uh we heard testimony that part of the
landing process and Landing license
process was that uh you had to file a
mandatory
report um and so if you remove the
license then you're removing the
required reporting and that was the
testimony as it was said to this
committee so am
I okay just want to make sure that I was
so with that being said it would seem to
me that
um a New Hampshire resident that's still
Landing these um whether you're paying
the fee or not um doesn't
change the ability for somebody to count
and
Report representative Harvey okay so um
it takes away that requirement because
you don't have to do it um but you're
right it could possibly be added and I
would feel much more comfortable if we
had some sort of a an amendment that put
that uh back in so that
um the statistics were still
there I've got a bunch of people hold on
rep Darby
first um I I would uh be interested in
hearing from um fishing game on on you
as you
suggested representative Ford did do you
have a I saw a hand go up so I didn't
know if you okay representative tutor I
might be wrong but I thought um
testimony said that um the fact that
they had a New Hampshire trapping
license to start with and now that this
is just New Hampshire residents they had
to report under the license so that's if
they have the trapping license but this
Landing license is separate from the
trapping
license correct the landing license
fee being waved for New Hampshire
residents doesn't stop the landing
license from being required for
non-residents or commercial people that
are non residents it's only stopping it
for New Hampshire
residents uh representative Brown first
then representative Hill um uh thank you
Mr
chair if anyone on the committee
knows when someone comes up to the dock
and they're they're going home for the
day who is there to know how many LW ERS
work that might be a question for
fishing game because I don't know how
they enforce that representative Hill
and then representative Khan so I do
know um having had one um the
Massachusetts license requires reporting
so if you have a non-resident
license and you're doing this um you're
getting your lobsters in Massachusetts
and coming to New Hampshire to with your
boat you are reporting so it's um so
that
part you're you're we're eliminating um
I would say 90% of that reporting
question I think at that point because
there is a a reporting that's done to
Massachusetts so the numbers do get
into um the Atlantic states
Fisheries project um but I would be
happy to work with representative Harvey
on a floor Amendment
um working out some way to try to create
this this reporting um it's certainly
not the intent of what we're trying to
do to avoid reporting and under and and
hurting the Fisheries in any way so if
there is something that needs to be done
in order to um augment the the reporting
accuracy I'm happy to do that with
you yeah yes I I just feel
like it's not your turn it's
representative Khan's turn first he's
had his hand up for a long time thank
you Mr chairman Mr chairman with your
permission I have a concern for a
quotation by the ficient game that I'm
going to read it uh in addition the
department has a concern with the
unenforceability of the Landing this
bill creates for example when checking a
vessel at sea or at Port law enforcement
would be unable to determine if the
lobster or crab landing were from a
recreational or commercial license in
another state so this was my concern
also Mr chairman thank you thank you I
would imagine that they would be able to
show their license from that other state
um to show they were licensed in that
other state but it is now representative
Reed's turn and then it'll be
representative Harvey's turn thank you
Mr chair so on the surface of this I
don't really see any real problem um I
don't see where it's taking away any
reporting requirements I don't see any
reason that a New Hampshire citizen who
is not selling um the catch should have
to pay a landing fee and I don't um see
that uh that the the issue of purpose is
an issue because we have intent through
a lot of criminal law as a matter of
fact and and those are the types of
things that have to be proven however
I've heard repeatedly today how these
things should be in rules it should be
in rules it should be in rules and this
has been in rules and we just voted down
a couple way more important way longer
standing things because it should be in
rules so I guess I'm going to have to
take the advice of my colleagues and
vote against this because it should be
in
rules thank you representative Reed
representative Harvey did you have
another uh it it just seems like we're
there's a lot of confusion on the
committee and a lot of discussion which
is a good thing but but when committees
have this much discussion and questions
it sort of points to the idea that maybe
the bill is not ready for prime time
yeah thank you for your comment any
further
comments representative Ford sorry um
thank you Mr chairman I I guess if the
concern is about the landing fees
shouldn't we focus on the that part
right and talk to fishing game about how
much the fee is to whether you're
getting four for your family or 20 for
your bigger family it should be the same
cost and I and I think we could talk
about the fees not necessarily saying
like it's free go out and do legal means
to getting your Lobster and then coming
back right we have the landing fees for
reason and until we fully fund the fish
and game department I say let them get
their money the best way they can so um
I would that's the reason I'm opposing
this outside of that it's confusing
because I don't understand launching and
landing and restriction and jurisdiction
and all that jazz but if the fishing
game are getting fees from Landing
whether it's for recreational or
commercial I say let them go for it and
I would I will uh um say that if that's
the case then obviously I won't be
supporting this bill but um if it's
about the fees let fishing game deal
with the fees and lure them if they see
fit um for that
representative
goalie thank you Mr chair
and the fees are set I believe in Rules
by the
director from what I understand but my
problem with it is still the reporting
and if we can get around that reporting
forward representative Brown so thank
you Mr chairman everyone so there isn't
a fee every time you land Lobster
there's only a fee for the landing
license is that correct thank you colon
Jordan would you like to take the mic
and tell us what you found out yes I
called and I apologize I couldn't get
him here today he should have been here
um but I called the lieutenant down
there I got a hold of him so the
reporting requirement comes in that
Landing license so if we exempt anyone a
resident or nonresident there will be no
reporting and his concern was you know
we won't have any idea of the resource I
said I understand that all I want you to
do is answer my question so the
reporting part of it would go away and
to answer your question representative
Brown the only way you would know so
that's required every I believe he said
every
month um and that's strictly enforced
because that's how they track the
resource the only other way you would
know what people get for lobsters the
way that we know it is when we stop the
boat which we do routinely and check
them and and that's one other way we
don't report that that's basically to
make sure they're in compliance with all
New Hampshire regulations so so they
file a report once a month with how much
they've taken that's what he said and
it's basically a voluntary thing uh it
comes with the requirement of the
license so he said they could still lie
and say they could oh yeah oh people can
lie in any of this oh yeah but if you
eliminate the license requirement you
would eliminate the requirement for
reporting too so both would go unless
you amended it all right we have uh
representative Harvey first and then
representative Derby so just to be clear
on my position I I'm not going to
support this but should it pass I'll be
happy to work with
you representative Darby thank you um I
was hoping to ask uh the colonel a
question um with respect to if
enforcement is ever done at the Docks
themselves you know for examp R yes in
fact we have details where officers are
assigned to the docks at the fish Co-op
and other places and then we um have two
uh two three Patrol bools that we go out
for yes thank you so much yes sir
representative hill before you
leave so how do you do if someone is
diving in Massachusetts on a
Massachusetts license they come back to
New Hampshire and you're reporting it
and they're turning around and Reporting
it as they are required to do under
their massachusett so we're not
reporting it representative Hill we're
check checking them to see limits make
sure they're within compliance of the
law the reporting part falls to the
fisherman we don't file a report on what
we see if that's your question so it's
both a vol it's a voluntary on the part
of the the person that's bringing it in
in both places no it's a requirement to
renew his license so if you get a
landing license which is now currently
required by law and you failed to report
you wouldn't get another Landing license
but um
follow up thank you um you do get
involved in this we're a little less
rigid in exec session so because we're
we're trying to flesh this out I'm only
a chairman um but it would seem to me
that
um it's possible not to if if there was
a person and all they did was dive using
their non-resident license in in
massachusett waters y it's possible that
that's the only place that they would be
reporting if they're not Landing in New
Hampshire that would be correct if they
land in New Hampshire they would have to
report in New Hampshire under the
current law and they do not report those
in on on their Massachusetts license
that I don't know I don't know what they
do in Mass I think they're reporting
twice yeah they they definitely do it in
New Hampshire if they if they have a
landing license it's required thank you
yes
sir
thank I got I would like to hear from
the director because he's been quiet for
so long
allene works with the atantic states
would actually a answer that question a
little
okay
absolutely we'd love to have Renee come
back up again get reported
under thank you Mr chairman so that yeah
the reporting requirements all come down
to The Landing State we do not operate
in a vacuum we have a standardized data
reporting program so for example example
a federal vessel fishing only out in
federal waters way
out we have a
requirement however they're required to
report to no officies we take their no
officies information as their
requirement for New Hampshire so all the
states are in coordination with each
other so if somebody was reporting that
information to Massachusetts they we
have that communication we identify that
as part of our licensing requirements um
um and the licensing requirement
triggers us to say hey we're going to
double check make sure this is compliant
and we're able to pull that information
from Massachusetts so yes thank you so
goalie thank you Mr chair and I just
want to follow up on this
because while we talk about diving in
only a few lobsters being
taken with this not all also
exempt someone who has a non-commercial
license in Maine coming back to New
Hampshire at they catch not having to
report as well because they're coming in
from out of state or from Massachusetts
the way this is worded if you had just
a um non-commercial license or just a um
what's the five trap or six trap license
Renee if you wouldn't mind I my
impression based on what you said before
is that they would have to report that
in main under their license that they
trapped in main with but go for it thank
you Mr chair so yes if they're catching
it under a license and that state has a
requirement the state of Maine is coming
into compliance they have a huge
population of fishers as you can imagine
and they're in the process of rolling
out mandatory reporting um they've been
given an exemption for partial reporting
to date to get statistics now we we know
that all of those data are super
important we have winds we have whales
we have all sorts of things going on in
the marine fisheries world uh including
a stock that has shown some challenges
so Lobster as you heard were having
gauge changes uh so yes if there is
reporting information there that's great
if not we collect that information we've
collected main fisherman information for
years because they're Landing in New
Hampshire and that license allows us to
identify those folks to make sure that
they are meeting the requirements that
we are
under thank you and by large population
of fishers I assume you mean the
profession and not the animal yes the
profession of I bet they have a lot of
the animal too Vice chair goalie you
followup but my question goes to if they
are not no longer required to get a
landing license here in New Hampshire
and catching in either Maine or
Massachusetts coming back they're not
required to report then if they're not
under the landing license here in New
Hampshire we would not be able to
identify them we would still need them
to report to stay in compliance with the
fishery management plan that allows us
to identify them and make sure we're in
compliance but yes anybody coming from
We're actually one of the only states
where you can land Lobster with a
license either the $50 fee for residents
or the $500 fee for non-residents to be
able to land Lobster taken from outside
the
jurisdiction or the $40 fee for your
five pots and then you don't even fish
here get
bring um any other
comments
questions okay thank you so much again
thank you and the clerk will call the
role it's on otpa represent Smith made
motion I I missed uh did we have someone
motion the amend rep Smith moved the the
amendment he also moved the amendment
and I believe a a bear seconded the
amendment thank
you now we're on otpa and we're on otpa
yes here all right otpa
1029 uh representative
goalie
no representative Khan no representative
Smith yes representative kofalt yes
representative Tudor yes representative
Brown yes representative Hill yes excuse
me representative wette yes
representative abar yes representative
Harvey no with my previous
caveat me write that in here
representative Reed no representative
Ford no representative Fox no
representative rung no Representative
shirle no representative PE no no
representative Rosner no representative
Derby no and chairman Spain
yes so that is eight yes 11 no we should
have 19 people here
yep motion fails for
otpa do we have another motion from the
committee I I make a motion for
itl motion for itl has been made by rep
Harvey do I have a second on that second
representative of Derby wow
shock do we have discussion on itl or
have we covered that
already representative
goalie thank you Mr chair I truly
believe that there could be a solution
to this problem whether or not we can do
it now between now and whenever but I
don't think it hurts to at least inum
study this versus itl to come to some
working around with the fishing game
department and those around us to see if
issue any other
discussion is anybody who's moved itl
motion no I I don't at this time thank
you though
okay representative Brown yeah I I would
agree with representative goalie I think
discussion okay well the motion's itl we
can see if that
passes clerk shall call the role
representative
goalie no representative Khan
yes representative Smith no
Representative kofalt no representative
tutor no representative Brown no
representative Hill no Representative
wette no Representative abar no
representative
Harvey yes representative
Reed yes representative Ford yes
representative Fox yes representative
rung yes representative shirtliff yes
representative PE yes representative
Rosner yes representative Derby yes and
chairman Spain
no we have 10 yes nine
no it pass itl passes will there be a
Minority Report representative
Smith okay I'm sure you can get some
help with that and uh majority reports
going to be written by
who oh I guess I am okay
Harvey's writing the majority report
this will be on the regular calendar
because it's a
split uh who's doing the minority
representative Smith representative
Smith on an otpa motion I would assume
A and right representative Harvey will
be doing the itl
right all right our last bill of the day
to exec I open now exec session on 1530
2 and I Look to representative AAR for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move to
OTP HB
1532 and do I have a
that we are open for discussion question
on the OTP motion representative a
bear's
recognized thank you Mr
chairman I believe this bill is
rights thank you any further discussion
on this
bill is that a hand up representative
goalie thank you Mr chair and well I do
agree and I think we heard from the
colonel some of these uh most of these
aspects that they could work with um
there were some issues uh that I feel
need to be addressed one calling it a
permit when we have no permit
available
um doesn't work and I think there was a
few concerns about the changing the
times once again to when tree STS could
be in place and removed um no I think
this bill just passed last year um they
spent a year getting people in line with
what's going on with promoting this and
putting it out there as much as they
could letting folks know that these
changes were coming
forth
and we're going
to six months before a new season comes
throw another change at
them and have to romote
what the requirements
are um I'm not sure how you we heard the
concerns about when you label your
camera using a tag well to put a tag on
a tree I'm assuming you have to use a
nail which no landowner wants put into
their trees especially those who are
loggers or Timberland owners Who harvest
their trees um neither do they want to
have to go around pulling these pla
cards off when they go to do their
logging so so um with that I
cannot um support this as it is I think
with a little bit of work it would be
workable to address those concerns of
Representative
Smith thank you I'm going to ask rep
peir to please check the table and see
if the blue sheet for 1532 is there I
hand them all in I thought because we
can't seem to find it up here I do have
oppose and representative Smith you
recogn now thank you Mr chair I just
want to I think there was a lot of
testimony and there is some confusion
with the intent of the bill that I
presented um with rep goal's just
statement regarding the placard that was
in the amendment that's not in the
original bill um the idea of the date so
my proposal is pretty clear it follows
current law all I'm doing is clarifying
current law right now says you can leave
a tree stand in there from uh August
August 1st right around to June 1st
that's current law but again the issue
is how is Colonel Jordan or his men or
women going to be able to enforce that
when he find finds a tree standing there
from January 1 to April 25th because the
person has to say I'm leaving it over
from December 31st because I can leave
it till June 1st so again I'm not
expanding or confusing this is
clarifying the window of time as to when
you can place a tree stand and clarifies
his enforcement for a fishing game it's
really and it's very confusing because
of the dates bouncing around but it's
pretty
straightforward I have the blue sheet
here uh two in favor five against inside
so we've got uh online four in support
one oppos and in the room two support
and five opposed and rep Smith I
neglected to ask you if you were
offering your Amendment on
this yeah not if the amend is going to
hurt the bill Mr
chairman and the am the amendment was
the placard part
correct I I would like to vote on that
Amendment because I think it helps the
bill
actually would you like to offer your
Amendment we can see if everybody likes
it and everybody or if everybody
doesn't sure all right so you offer
Amendment what's the number on that let
me it out and I'll need a second for
that Amendment who would like to second
the amendment it's Amendment
0024 offered you got that
number offered by rep Smith and it's
seconded by rep Brown and now we are
open for discussion of the amendment uh
rep Smith would you like to go over
again what your Amendment does sure
thank you Mr chairman so the amendment
was asked by obviously constituent in
the field because he has a camera it's
got uneven sides it's it's just not a
Smooth Spot to place his name and
address or contact information she said
why can't I put it on the cam strap or
on a placard the amendment doesn't
authorize it to be nailed into a tree
frankly that's already illegal you can't
nail a nail into someone's private
property which is a tree that's already
against the law um so a placard you
could hang that placard from the strap
of the camera you can hang that placard
from the tree via string you can hang it
from a tree branch you don't have to
nail it or screw it to the tree uh
matter of fact in baiting rules I think
for be baiting it's actually illegal to
physically screw it into the tree
obviously unless you own that tree so
the amendment just puts Clarity even
Colonel Jordan I if I'm can speak to
this I think he put guidance out to his
officers to allow it to be labeled in a
broader fashion but guidance within the
department is one thing I think you need
Clarity in the law and that Clarity is
here by allowing it on a strap or a
placard or the
camera okay further discussion on the
amendment representative Darby thank you
Mr chair well I don't support the bill
in general I definitely support this
amendment having hung lots of uh cameras
myself I don't I think it would be a
pain in the butt to actually have to
label them in a way that is waterproof
um and people can see it so this is this
makes a lot of sense to
me further
discussion representative goalie thank
you Mr chair and I I don't
see an issue with labeling cameras
themselves um nothing more than
um taking a fine point Sharpie and a
piece of duct tape with your name and
address on it and sticking that to a
camera once it's written on on a flat
piece of on a table
um I don't see where the issue is um
they are square some of them are around
but tape is flexible and that's probably
one of the most easiest I think we've
all done um address labels in our lives
on stuff and they all work and Sharpies
are waterproof um they wear well they'll
last more than a season I can testify
that as you have to put your name on
address on arrows that are out in the
woods in the weather all the time they
hold up so that's where I'm at when I
can attest that Sharpies work well on
arrows on the Fletching don't write it
on the shaft it wears off um any further
discussion on the amendment sure
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
can anyone in the room verify if it's
illegal to put nails into a
tree
it is
not without it's not legal without
permission thank
you without permission you cannot put a
nail in a
tree if it's your own tree you can do
what you
want okay uh any further discussion on
the amendment seeing none the clerk may
amendment
ignore our our banter up here uh
no representative Khan yes
representative Smith yes representative
kofalt yes representative Tudor yes
representative Brown yes representative
Hill yes representative wette yes
representative AAR yes representative
Harvey yes representative Reed yes
representative Ford yes representative
Fox yes representative Rong
no Representative shirtliff no
representative pear
yes representative Rosner yes
representative Derby yes and chairman
Blain
yes that's 16 yes three no all right
brings us to
otpa and is there any more discussion on
the bill as amended representative
Khan thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
is it okay if I ask a couple of question
to representative Smith who is the Prime
sponsor feel free thank you Mr chairman
and thank you m representative Smith to
taking my question question is we heard
over and over that um the last year the
bill we passed you try to make that law
a better law with this new bill and we
heard that uh did uh that everybody is
asking give little time do you agree
with that that give little time at least
a year is only 34 days old
law uh thank you for the question uh no
this bill has Ser excuse me current law
has serious flaws and if we know there's
a flaw everyone can see it here we've
read it why not fix it we've spent a
whole entire hour discussing this we
have an opportunity to correct the law
going forward let's do it now why
wait thank you thank you thank you
further discussion representative Darby
thank you Mr chair um as we heard a few
minutes ago um uh number of uh people
were opposed to this including the Farm
Bureau Timber Owners Association and
very importantly um fishing game
although they um they did say they were
willing to work on some of the the pr y
concerns the thing that is most
concerning to me is um the inability to
place um to place cameras um for uh
endangered um and non-game species which
are used for studies right now that this
would prohibit without um without
permission and as we heard um the
telling one person is the worst way to
keep secret so that's why I'll be
opposing this otpa thank
you thank you any further discussion
role we're right on 4:30 represent thank
you everyone no representative Khan no
representative Smith yes representative
Kofa yes representative Tudor yes
representative Brown is yes
representative Hill yes representative
wette yes representative AAR yes
representative Harvey no representative
Reed no representative Ford no
representative Fox no representative
rung no Representative shirtliff no
representative PE no representative
Rosner no representative Derby no and
chairman Spain yes yes 8 yes 11 no otpa
fails is there a
motion Mr Vice chair are you going to
make a
motion
I will move inum study and I truly
believe that with some work with fishing
game we'll get this language correct and
I think we all agree on these changes
looking going forward that's why I
looked at you is there a second on that
representative Darby interim study has
been moved and seconded is there
discussion on interim study or does
everyone want to go home at
4:30 too late okay the clerk may call
the
rooll
time all right this is also why I won't
let him leave my
committee representative goalie interim
study representative goalie yes
representative Khan yes representative
Smith yes reluctantly representative kof
fault yes I don't have a column for that
representative tutor yes representative
Brown yes
representative uh Hill yes yeah
representative wette yes representative
AAR yes representative
Harvey
no oh
wait you put them all in the nose I did
okay hang on let's do this there you
go relabel The Columns that's a smart
go representative
Reed
yes representative Ford yes oh boy
representative Fox yes representative
rung yes representative sherff yes
representative peer yes representative
Roser yes representative Derby yes and
chairman Spain yes 18 yes one no
consent no one against we're going to go
with consent who made the motion on that
uh representative goalie representative
goalie I expect a small blurb from you
it all blurbs are due by noon tomorrow
for everybody who's has to write one
thank you very much and I appreciate all
everybody's dedicated time today have
yourself a great evening and uh this is
our last Committee hearing until we have
hard